today
the fbi raided the home of the gop front
runner
for the gubernatorial primaries in
michigan he was then arrested in rel in
connection with january 6th so there's
two potential scenarios
the democrat doj the biden doj has
weapon has been become weaponized and is
going after their political rivals or
you have a an extremely popular
insurrectionist candidate so pick one i
guess
there's another report that's been going
around about whistleblowers claiming the
fbi has been purging their ranks of
conservatives so honestly the truth may
be closer to the middle this guy ryan
kelly is the frontrunner in the gop
primary to go up against whitmer he was
at the capitol
allegedly he's fanning people telling
him to come in and saying things like
it's war i don't know for sure
if the evidence presented by
the the federal government in their
claims is true then this guy was there
he never went in the building
he's being charged with i believe four
misdemeanors
and from those four uh misdemeanors they
raided his house they've arrested him
and coincidentally it's happening right
as they're doing those uh those hearings
on january 6th so um
you know i i can only uh think that it's
just breaking down
joe biden went on jimmy kimmel and he
jokingly said you got to arrest all the
republicans
because jimmy kimmel was like how do you
how do you do this
how do you play fair if republicans
aren't playing fair
anybody's been paying attention to the
news and knows the facts knows the
republicans aren't playing at all
they're just sitting on their hands the
democrats aren't playing fair but
they've convinced their voter base that
it's actually the republicans who are
doing things they're not actually doing
anything
i think it's all falling apart
last night as many of you know we did
one of the longest shows we've had a
long time four and a half hours not on
purpose now three and a half hours was
just dead air because luke made some
great points in that time that was out
the smartest he's ever sounded when we
were when we were outside for those
three and half hours uh waiting for the
police luke gave this tremendous speech
and it was the greatest speech i've ever
given yeah you just had to have been
there yes
so
so this happens and um we're in maryland
we're we're relatively close to where
kavanaugh lives and so this was a factor
in in what happened we had a credible
threat
considering that day we got news that
someone had attempted to kidnap and
murder a supreme supreme court justice
we had to take it we had to take it
seriously and uh there's a whole bunch
of other stuff that's going on
now those those
terrorists went back to kavanaugh's
house and the reason why i call them
that is
when you have people
violate the law to intimidate a judge
then someone attempts to kidnap and
murder that judge
then they come back to illegally protest
in front of the house that's a threat
they are trying to use fear and
intimidation so we're going to talk
about all of this stuff
uh i guess gas prices over five bucks so
that's that's particularly brutal but
we'll talk about all that and returning
for a do-over it's tommy altman yeah
well thanks for having me back uh
hopefully it's not nearly as eventful as
last night no it's good it was going
really well it was like a great show and
then we had to flee the building and you
know we had a lot of fun we had great
conversations out there too bad they
weren't all recorded but um no looking
forward to it yeah so so for those that
aren't familiar who are you what you do
yes my name is tommy altman i'm running
for congress in the second district of
virginia it's where i was born and
raised i'm an air force a special ops
combat veteran i combat tours on the
ground in afghanistan iraq disabled
veteran ordained minister small business
owner i owned a tattoo studio over there
in the district for the last five years
and honestly man just running because
i'm sick and tired of seeing where we're
the direction we're moving as a nation i
got sons and i want to make sure that
our next generation had the same
freedoms and opportunities everybody
else had right on we got luke hey guys i
got one simple message for you here
today that it's not the news it's an
establishment press release and if you
agree with that statement and one on on
a t-shirt you could on the best
political shirts.com we have a lot of
important things to discuss especially
the fbi in michigan absolutely awful
track record especially when it comes to
their destruction of plots lots to talk
about there's there's a potential
connection between the whitmer and this
guy absolutely and i i think there's
some uh homeless guy that snuck in here
that's not supposed to be in here i
don't know
yeah well thank you i'm glad i'm glad
that we have somebody here who's willing
to take my side against this
unbelievably unfair bullying
wow ridiculous yeah
it's called speaking truth to power
truth well i'm glad you're acknowledging
it more powerful than you i don't know
this is gonna be fun with his constant
victimization
i am seamus coughlin of freedom tunes we
just released a cartoon today that i
think you guys are really going to enjoy
it's pretty hard hitting and solid and i
think came just in time for pride month
also just launched a website
freedomteams.com if you go over there
and become a member for five bucks a
month you can support independent
content you'll also get an extra cartoon
a week which is exclusive and the rest
of the public doesn't get so thank you
so much and uh i really think you'll
like it go over there good cartoons
thank you so much i really appreciate
that okay they're okay i mean as an
artist i enjoyed them yeah thank you
thank you yeah we were just watching
them before the show and they are truly
wonderful we always enjoy our freedom
tunes sorry the potato man is good in
this instance go check out freedom
yeah all right let's get going
i'm not a huge fan of that descriptor
before we get started my friends head
over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen i love this
stuff i i skate frequently and i gotta
keep my bones healthy and strong my skin
my joints my nails if you are an aging
millennial you got to take this stuff
seriously head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
your supply of ageless multi-collagen up
to 51 off and they include a 60-day
money-back guarantee you'll get the
healthy aging support of collagen in its
ideal forms five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
essential to optimally support an array
of full body benefits hydrolyzed
collagen peptides meaning better and
faster digestibility to support maximum
benefits and for every order today they
will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics or rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth there's no clumping unlike other
supplements and you will get free
shipping with every order free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust's team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin
so again head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com support
biotrust they are one of our sponsors we
really do appreciate it but don't forget
to also check out timcast.com
this time we're gonna have that members
only segment we weren't able to do it
last night because we are we were
outside the house waiting for the police
to finish sweeping the building
as a member you are supporting our work
while we deal with such things but also
we put up monday through thursday at 11
p.m members only shows we're going to
have one of those tonight you're helping
support our journalist we just hired a
couple more journalists check out adrian
norman he's awesome we actually had him
on the show hopefully hopefully to have
him hope to have him back soon
and smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share this youtube video
this live stream wherever you can if you
really want to support us or just share
timcast.com where people can now come
and watch the show
smash that like button again not too
many times just make sure you did and
let's jump into that first story
from timcast.com
leading michigan gop gubernatorial
candidate ryan kelly raided arrested in
connection with january 6 protest
teamcast.com reports the candidate was
raided on june 9th on misdemeanor
charges related to the protest he is
facing four misdemeanor charges
knowingly entering or remaining in a
restricted building disorderly
destructive conduct knowingly engaging
in any act of physical violence against
a person or property in a restricted
building or grounds and willfully
injuring or committing depredation
against property of the u.s the charging
documents do not accuse kelly of ever
entering the building he is accused of
gesturing for people to move forward
while on the capitol steps they also say
that i guess he he assisted in someone
pulling down
he's also accused of using his hands to
support another rioter who was pulling a
metal barricade so they have photos
that they argue is this guy now here's
what it's important
ryan kelly is currently polling at 19
he is up four points he is the gop front
runner for the primary to go up against
gretchen whitmer
so we have one of two scenarios
we either have the doj being weaponized
to shut down popular pro-trump
candidates or
we have a
popular candidate who is an
insurrectionist now think about either
scenario if you're a democrat you're
looking to the sky and you're like this
guy was at january 6.
and he's winning right what does that
say about the american people in that
perspective now i certainly don't
believe that narrative i think what
we're seeing is the weaponization of the
doj against political rivals yeah this
guy should have been there he shouldn't
have been gesturing people if that's
what he was doing sure the rioters
should be charged but to see an fbi raid
on a prominent politician over
misdemeanors it's clearly to me right
this is another question just really
quickly right before an election right
you know when they had the footage they
knew this was going on i mean how long
did it take them to to process
everything to and and now they're doing
it sorry
it's been a year and a half yeah i
wouldn't say if if he is uh an
insurrectionist he's not a very good one
that's all he did yeah well and this is
the point right they have this entire
insurrectionist narrative and the idea
is that the sitting president of the
united states who is the
commander-in-chief and has control over
the entirety of the armed forces right
decided to overthrow the government and
have a coup and he did this
by having a bunch of civilians without
any guns
enter a building they weren't supposed
to be in and and many of them didn't
even go in the building many of them
didn't go in the building and many of
them were waived in by police officers
and didn't do anything violent and it's
not even many of them it's a fraction of
a percent right that did i'm just
imagining you know these these hearings
the hearings are happening now i don't
care and they're going to be like this
was a plot
by a sitting president to overthrow this
country a city and i'm going to explain
to you how he did it yeah he vaguely
mentioned something about walking
towards the capitol yeah and then what
happened took a selfie towards the
capitol a bunch of people some some
people rioted maybe a few hundred and
then about half of them went in the
building
and then a bunch of people were let in
by the police and they walked around
taking selfies with those cops and then
left peacefully
yeah exactly this is this this is the
sitting president commander-in-chief in
control of the military literally has
access to the button that launches nukes
and his plot to overthrow the united
states government and become some kind
of dictator was to have civilians none
of whom are virtually none of whom
brought any guns there were no go
towards the capitol vaguely gesture that
they had in that area this is a coup it
was the worst coup ever in the history
of the world well these hearings that
we're going to be hearing about on
national television the january six
committee hearings they're putting out
all the stops they want to make sure
that this is going to be a spectacle
they brought in the former president of
abc news the man that squashed the
jeffrey epstein story that suppressed it
that spiked it that made sure that this
was the famous story the amy robert
robichav
project veritas story
roebuck where she specifically said we
had bill clinton we had all the evidence
we had this years ago and it was
squashed by abc news that man that was
in charge of that is going to be now
presenting the showcase spectacle that
is going to be presented to the american
public in just a few hours from now so
you can only expect how corrupted and
how bad and how just emotionally
manipulative it's going to be
attempted to sway the american public
towards seeing something that that again
has been highly manipulated from day one
i want to make another point here this
is something that actually came from
polling data and i've quoted this on the
show before but
more people who were polled from the
general public want to see an
investigation into the 2020 riots than
want to see an investigation into
january 6th so where's that isn't it a
threat to our democracy that we're
investigating an event which a minority
wants to see investigated rather than
something the majority wants to
investigate i'm pretty sure more people
want hillary clinton investigated uh
yeah i think even a large portion of
democrats did or just released the list
of uh you know the clients for maxwell
that's right you know yeah that would be
enough and then elon musk just a few
days ago even asked how come the doj
hasn't leaked that information nope and
that's a very important question that i
think we should be asking because we are
seeing the doj weaponized in a very
strong way we just had um another trump
administration member arrested just a
few days ago at the airport uh peter
navarro
he's been on the show before and he was
in contact with the federal authorities
and he said you need anything you need
me to come in you need me to provide
evidence let's talk we'll work it out
they set him up at the airport and he
says he was treated like an allocated
terrorist which which is not surprising
in these days especially with just how
overbearing and just how insane
institutions like the fbi have been that
just a few weeks ago we found out set up
this whole grit and richmore kidnapping
plot which again was totally uh unfolded
as a jury ruled that the people there
were entrapped by the fbi the jury no no
the gretchen whitman rip more whitmer
whitmer
which more i think is a little bit more
better potentially appropriate it
actually is better
to slip i think
luke makes a very good point here uh so
the fbi raids his house over
misdemeanors we saw an instance uh when
we were talking i believe with nick
cersei about his film capital punishment
of these two old ladies who had the fbi
knock at their door because they walked
through the capitol after they were
welcomed in by police and then
we go to the epstein story the fbi
raided his island and there has not been
a single indictment related to it you're
telling me they didn't find enough
evidence to indict a single police
the fbi had witnesses coming forward for
over 30 years and they decided to ignore
those witnesses in that very specific
case the fbi aided and abetted this
larger international trafficking and
extortion operation which which again
shows you just how badly corrupted
institutions could be inside of
washington dc leading to the suffering
of thousands of children in unspeakable
ways what we should want i believe as a
society is to know why our government is
so bad at actually investigating anybody
that's going to mess with little kids
how why are we so bad at that
that i mean historically over and over
again this is what our justice system is
actually really bad at and i think the
vast majority of americans want to
protect children absolutely if there's
any purpose of a justice system right
right
bad ats or
yeah i think they're good at not
investigating right i think they have a
goal like the same thing went on for how
long yeah over 30 plus years right that
we know of and then the first round came
forward the first victim came from the
first guy to do something like this and
get away with it under the government's
nose exactly so i i look at this story
and uh this was like a holy moment
when uh
when this guy got arrested because
any way you cut it right the it's i
think luke put it well they're doing
this
only a few months before the midterm
this guy is the front runner they're
shutting down a front runner aside from
that this is a guy who's done multiple
rallies where he said stop the steal and
all those rallies and things like that
people agree with him and they vote for
him right you know i think what you see
with like youtube they ban anybody who
agrees with trump or pushes that
narrative because they're doing
everything they can to suppress this
exactly this yeah
it's it's it's all part of the same
machine
yeah the interesting thing if you
actually go back and look at the the
descriptions that they that they used
all the things that he did that were
wrong
they actually described everything that
happened with the blm riots and you know
so we don't we don't use the same level
of justice we're not measuring the same
things for both of these instances and
like you said most people really do want
to know what happened with these
with these riots and i think this is
absolutely crazy i i think that the this
is what you're going to see from the
democrat party in the midterms they're
going to run on three things you're
going to run on abortion they're going
to run on the second amendment take away
our second amendment and they're going
to run on january 6th because what else
are they going to run on well yeah they
don't have a good economy but even with
those issues the particular stance that
they've taken on those are all losing
issues so gun control has been a losing
issue for the left for years and years
and years like this is not something
they've been successful with and then
even with their particular position on
abortion i've said a million times on
this show i'm pro-life
most pro-choice people are not as
extreme as the democratic party as with
their position so when they say
and everyone was arguing this oh if the
supreme court overturns roe they're
going to be handing the election of the
democrats absolutely not because what
the dems are going to do
which is what they have done is come out
with the most extremist
abortionist legislation that most
pro-choice people are going to say they
wouldn't be willing to accept right we
talked about it yesterday in california
they're talking about post-term abortion
it's a huge problem so but go back to
january 6 i believe that this is what
the le the radical left is using to
squash political dissent and that's the
that's the real problem is if we're
using this i mean we have political
prisoners right now in the united states
yeah yeah that's that's both sides of
the aisle should this would be grave
concern to all of us because then what's
the what's what's the next step what are
we going to do with society if we now
have political prisoners let me let me
let me go back in time
20 2016 donald trump was saying lock her
up because you'd be in jail you said
hillary clinton start people started
chanting and lock her up a lot of people
on the left were like this is dangerous
rhetoric i agree it is of course i think
hillary clinton has done a lot of
nefarious stuff and should be
investigated take a look at this story
from timcast.com
biden breaks his 118 day streak of no
interviews with appearance on jimmy
kimmel live jokes about sending
republicans to jail wow same thing wow
it's all projection yep but we're at
this point now
where joe biden goes on this primetime
show i think they only get like a
million to two million viewers anyway so
it's not like it and they're mostly old
people so you're competitive
i mean i think we get more in the key
demo than they do
but he goes on this show and it's funny
to him to say you gotta you gotta send
the republicans to jail but everyone
laughs and they cheer for it
we're we're beyond the point where
there's negotiation
right now i'm looking at some of these
other prominent leftists on youtube and
they're all like january 6th hearings
and they don't know or care about what
really happened no i'll give you a good
example because i love bringing it up
when i said on this show
when it comes to trespassing charges a
person has to have been warned for it to
be criminal right the people on january
6 who were led in the building by police
could not have known because it's a
public building and the cops opened the
door and let them in
now the rioters the people who fought
with cops on the other side of the
building yeah right they're going to get
arrested they're going to be charged
they were fighting it was violent
but they're we're going to see a lot of
people who fight it and they're going to
say i wasn't trespassing the door was
opened we've already seen it happen the
young turks run a story saying i'm an
idiot i'm making it up
they they they conflate
what really happened that day between
the different sides of the building with
all just rioting
and it turns out i was right the whole
time but those are the kind of people
who are going to watch jimmy kimmel and
they're going to cheer for this and
there's no negotiating with them because
i can say to them they can watch my
video where i say specifically the
rioters should be charged and the people
on the other side of the building who
are led by cops you can't charge or it's
going to be difficult and they should be
able to see like they should be able to
respond very simply with like okay those
are fact statements instead they just
say we don't care we want to go to war
with you we want to hate you
so i don't see how there's
reconciliation i don't see how there's
there's a resolution if we can it's like
it's almost like looking into a a portal
into a parallel universe watching this
interview with joe biden jimmy kimmel
jimmy kimmel's like the republicans
don't play by the rules you know how do
you how he's like well if if we play
like them then then we're gonna we're
gonna our democracy's in jeopardy and
i'm like what are the republicans doing
right literally what have they done have
they passed bills no they're in the
minority so what are they doing that is
breaking the rules they're not doing
anything
but joe biden go on tv and they all
believe it
yeah i think watching that it's like you
know scott adams talks about one screen
two movies playing the same time we're
all saying something different right
i think if you know the truth you're not
on the left if you believe the lies
you're on the left that's what happens
well you so you mentioned trump saying
that hillary would be in jail and
compared the two part of what's
different about this is biden is
referring much more vaguely to
republicans and certainly he's referring
to republican political leaders i think
we can infer that but donald trump was
talking about a specific
political leader who is viewed by the
vast majority of the public as being
corrupt 50 friends commitment but who
who committed who committed a specific
crime and it committed a specific cri
exactly exactly yeah i mean because look
i was in the military and having the
clearance that i had if you just left a
document or a folder on the table that
said top secret if you leave that in
there empty and you leave the room you
can be charged oh for sure it's an empty
it's an empty folder oh but it was just
yoga emails right that's what she said
look we all smash our phone with a
hammer every now and again that's true
yeah well you know when when when uh you
know you work for the government you're
supposed to take a hammer to your your
phone so that
it's the craziest thing they did but
they did it right and i heard people say
well maybe she didn't take because
there's courses that you have to take
when i whenever
so they're like well maybe she didn't
take the course and likely she didn't
but it doesn't mean that you're not
culpable for violating law yeah well you
have a clearance is not an excuse right
she should be according to the law
disqualified from holding office for
destroying public record yep
now
that it's never going to happen i mean
she's disqualified because people aren't
going to vote for her
see that's the funny thing though right
voting works and a lot of people just
want to say it doesn't work but i'm like
donald trump is kind of proof that if
people look nobody wanted to vote for
hillary clinton
slightly more wanted donald trump
donald trump wins the vast majority of
people even 18 months before they voted
for donald trump if you'd have told them
you're going to vote for donald trump
for president they would have left it
you know yes that's the reality a lot of
prominent never trumpers are now on the
trump train right there you know we've
had people on the show where in 2015-16
they were like trump's awful we can't
allow him and they're like well you know
he wasn't that bad after all he ended up
voting for him
i think there's a lot wrong with donald
trump but i certainly think he did he
did a pretty good job in a lot of areas
and it's remarkable how we went from
2019 no pandemic best numbers of our
lives best economy then a pandemic
happens and everyone's like it's trump's
fault when it's like it was the
governor's even right now i have no
problem saying a lot of the issues we're
facing are remnants of what the
governors did and it's not just
democrats the democrats are the ones who
held on forever and the republicans
backed away from it but i don't blame
biden for the fact we had a pandemic i
blame him for a specific policies and
he's enacted since he became president
right you have people all the time
especially campaigning they want to know
where you're staying on trump and the
single question that you respond to
people with and this is the god's honest
truth is listen the reality is for the
most americans what we really care about
is how much money we're paying at the
pump and how much we're paying for food
that's what we care about and so i tell
people are you better today
under this administration or two years
ago for me it's very clear that my
family my business we were much better
two years ago than everybody was whether
they want to admit it or not where do
you stand on trump that's that is the
stance i mean i voted for the man twice
i'll be happy vote for him again are you
kidding me i would vote for just about
anybody compared to this [ __ ] that's in
office right now are you kidding me i
vote for you for president i've only
known you for two days that's how bad he
is
[Laughter]
no i mean let's be real luke would be a
substantially better president than joe
biden and it's not because luke is a
good good at policy it's because joe
biden is a decrepit old senile man
senile old man that's not a compliment
you're not helping me out here yeah it's
like on a scale of like one to ten where
one is just the absolute worst and
you're just like something's wrong with
you and ten is you're the best leader
ever luke's a four and biden's a one oh
wow okay so it makes move
that makes luke it's four times better
than biden and to be fair like first act
as president of the united states was to
be abolished the u.s government of the
united states and make everything states
rights yeah well you just went from the
foreign decide everything for themselves
abolish all the government agencies the
atf immediately irs federal reserve all
going up going back on the gold standard
uh three things that are legal
that's kind of weird but i can't i was
born
i was born in poland i came to be a
president oh man oh but thank you but
thank you thank you for taking care of
me
haven't we only had like one irish
catholic president uh yeah yes i believe
kennedy uh okay so that didn't work out
well yeah exactly it worked out well for
him yeah yeah yeah
he tried to move against the big banks
and uh you know
you could put a pumpkin in the white
house and the country would run better
we did
yeah we sure did yeah it was very
important
it went really well the policies are un
listen
the reality is the policies under trump
made us stronger and a stronger america
makes a safer world we've seen that i
mean for crying out loud the man had
peace deals in the middle east i'm 41
years old we heard our whole life it's
never gonna happen there's never gonna
be peace in the middle east and he
started making peace deals i mean how do
how i don't understand they panicked
when that happened yeah they should have
they didn't like it no yeah the
establishment was like but but we need
to blow up kids in the middle east what
are we gonna do we can have
they're so mad they're so livid trump
was getting our troops out of syria he's
got a timeline for for getting out of
afghanistan he was constantly
complaining about how he got troops
everywhere he's like why do we have
troops in in germany this makes no sense
and i'm just like this guy knows what's
up well you know he he did move him
around he did bomb certain areas as well
but he did move troops out of somalia he
bombed terrorism uh generals of
terrorist
to to organizat specifically when it
comes to american foreign policy and the
unaccountable drone strikes but uh he
did take troops out of somalia and stop
the operations there biden just a couple
weeks ago introduced more troops into
somalia and just two days ago started
launching airstrikes inside of that
region
just two days ago so look the reality is
anybody who advocates for war as
somebody who's been to it twice has
either never been to war or is profiting
from it that's my stance on it yeah i
believe that the vast majority of
americans do not want their sons and
daughters to go to wars and foreign
soils spill american blood on foreign
soils that has nothing to do with
american interests that's i'm telling
you right now that's where the vast
majority of americans and what happened
to what happened that was a left
position that was like the left was all
about this right and i remember the
2000s when it was just all protests
obama's like i'm gonna get our troops up
and then he put our troops in let's get
him let's bring him back home bring back
our boys and then look where we are well
it's funny
obama said that he was gonna withdraw
the troops draw down our forces the
first thing he does when he get when he
gets in he says that's bombing families
immediately yeah now the milwaukee
family which uh the biden administration
targeted those children and then trump
targeted as soon as he got into office
as well so as soon as trump got in
office there was a commando right in
yemen where
now here's here's the challenge
barack obama ordered a drone strike
which did result in the killing of a 16
year old american citizen in yemen why
the u.s bombed a civilian restaurant in
yemen we have no real explanation they
said oh we're trying to get a terror
leader and they end up blowing up some
kid an american citizen
now a lot of people point this out i
think it's fair to donald trump one of
the first things he does when he gets
inaugurated when he becomes president is
order a commando raid which resulted in
the death of a seven-year-old girl
abdulrahman alaaki's little sister
however
the the death of
abdulrahman al-awlaki the 16 year old is
well known and documented and admitted
the death of the little girl is claimed
by the family so there is a different
difference there
i still think we shouldn't be trump
should not have been ordering commando
raids in yemen or helping saudi arabia
in this manner but there's a slight
difference in the confirmation of these
stories
yeah lots of things especially when it
comes to geoplastic geopolitics that
become a lot more complicated a lot
deeper down the rabbit hole than we
could even understand on them especially
when we hear about the public stories
and what really happened there's usually
a big discrepancy between between both
of those oh absolutely i mean quite
honestly
we were talking about it earlier we
really don't even know what to believe
anymore there's so much there's so much
propaganda and this is from i mean not
just our government from everywhere
there's so much propaganda now that
nobody knows what to believe anymore
that's a huge problem if the american
people don't know who to trust for
information
it's almost like that's on purpose it's
a demoralization you're a besman officer
but i mean especially about foreign
policy right it's really difficult to
get information about that and report
accurately and so much of we the
information we get turns out to be
untrue you mentioned that uh you're a
veteran it's also interesting because i
found that that was not as important an
issue to me until i started becoming
friends with people who had fought in
some of these wars and they ended up red
pilling me on american foreign policy
there's this idea that veterans are
pro-war in some way i have found that
absolutely hasn't been the case and if
i'm not mistaken was was ron paul not
the most donated to candidate by us us
service members yeah absolutely yeah so
the people who actually see this stuff
almost always end up opposing and his
policy was non-interventionalism
the troops back into the united states
zero
priority issues here inside of the
united states rather than of course
being the policeman of the world which
which i think there's some important
context to especially with the way that
plan has played out in places like
afghanistan that was an absolute mess
and a huge investment of wasted money
that made the situation that much worse
on the ground and i i just want to say
this i'm glad you mentioned that just in
case this didn't hit home for any of the
audience members who aren't entirely
familiar with ron paul and maybe just
sort of vaguely know him as libertarian
probably the most anti-war presidential
candidate this country has ever had yeah
dr no yep
let's talk about uh where we're going
domestically though we have this story
from timcast.com it's all from
timcats.com
pro-abortion protesters show up at the
home of justice kavanaugh hours after
man arrested for failed assassination
attempts so this story was from
yesterday
but you know this morning
uh let me let me tell you guys
you know about what happened last night
if you watched the show we were forced
to evacuate the building there was a
credible threat
it sucks
after we came back in
jeremy hambly of the quartering was
swatted and we believe by the same
person there were similarities to to the
incidents uh all those are ours was a
was substantially different there were
enough similarities to where we think it
was the same person
upon seeing that
you know so jeremy of the quartering
he's got a big youtube channel they
apparently pinned him on the ground
cuffed him they had pointed guns in the
face of his wife
and it's it's particularly brutal
i wake up and i see this story
that a man so so first let's let's let's
go back in time
people announced their intent to protest
at the homes of the supreme court
justices which is a federal crime
merit garland says so what
genseki encourages it she says we
certainly encourage more of this she
outright said they encourage it they are
outright saying to commit crimes
and there's no justice
i warned
if people go to these homes and they are
not held to account and being held to
account means you get a slap on the
wrist they take you to the department
take a picture of you and you leave
you that you go to court and the judge
says don't do it again and that's the
end of it just slap on the rest nothing
happens to you right but that line is
set that we will arrest you because it's
non-violence of disobedience i said if
we don't do that they will escalate to
the next point well they jumped the
shark i mean the next the next
escalation would have been like
vandalism but a dude shows up with zip
ties crowbar a knife a glocks i think in
a glock 17.
yeah it's gonna be a bad night it was
going to be a very bad night and uh this
guy ends up confessing
turns himself in
and the protesters came back
and there's no justice unbelievable
after everything we go through and we're
not that far away right okay we're i
don't want to say just how close we are
relatively close
and there there's there's no justice
there's no law i can't see
people in this country having confidence
in the government when they know that
not only is one political faction
allowed to
just blatantly flagrantly break the law
but that they are encouraged to do so by
the white house press secretary and here
we are after an assassination
assassination attempt the only thing i
hope for is that
they announced next week there's going
to be monday and wednesday opinion
rulings which is going to be big because
i believe this may be the last chance
they have to issue their opinions on roe
and casey and the gun control
legislation out of new york
hopefully brett kavanaugh sees this and
he just goes
people should have guns
constitutional carry nationwide love it
i certainly hope so otherwise i think
what we're looking at is
we've been swatted several times
we've had credible threats we had a
threat in nashville we were we're going
to play a show at john rich's place and
then we actually had a very serious
incident occur and they were like we
can't we can't do it there's like kids
and there's families
so we were forced to cancel it
this is the state of politics in this
country
during the generation that watched
hannity you know rachel maddow the older
generation
they're not
they're not doing these things
you look at that splc poll that we
showed up we pulled up several uh
several times now the older generation
overwhelmingly does not favor political
assassinations right
young women
republican and democrat young men
republican and democrat over one-third
of all these support political
assassinations with with democratic men
being the highest at 44 of them
supporting assassinations and this is
where we are which says to me
in the next 10 years
it's going to be
if if this sentiment is this prominent i
can only imagine the next 10 15 and 20
years it's going to become mainstream
and normal to see this kind of violence
yeah i mean it honestly is a and we
talked about a little bit yesterday this
is the value of human life issue it
really is i mean the fact that these
people showed back up to uh brett
kavanaugh's house nobody even were they
not thinking what about their kids what
about their wife what how are they
feeling right now they believe that
they're that their husband and that
their father was just you know the
target of an assassination you don't
have any compassion well no they don't
they want power yeah and this is the
best opportunity for them in their minds
why brett kavanaugh is scared someone
just tried to kidnap and murder him now
the protest is a threat yeah and they
don't have to say the words because it's
already been made yeah well and i would
argue the protest has been a threat the
entire time what is the purpose of
protesting outside of the home of
someone who never has to run for
re-election who's in a lifetime
appointment you're not telling them that
they're going to lose at the ballot box
because public opinion is against them
no so what are you trying to show them
yeah what are you trying to show them by
saying we are a bunch of angry people
outside of your house who don't want you
to make a particular decision yeah
you're trying to intimidate them i mean
exactly imagine being a person like oh
hey someone just tried to assassinate
that person and his family let's go
outside of his home and call him a liar
like what is wrong with people
it makes absolutely no rational sense at
all and where's the humanity you know
where's the caring where's the
consideration of like hey maybe this is
not the best time to go scream at him
and his family they know they're allowed
to do it they have been encouraged to
break the law by the current
administration there are zero
consequences and if the way to get their
political agenda across and either
establish the social order that they
want to establish or protect what they
already have in place means that you
have to intimidate someone or they get
killed they are clearly okay with that
they are clearly completely comfortable
that and no one's talking about the fact
this guy had zip ties who who even says
he was just going after the justice
himself you're right he was outside of
his family's house he could have had a
plot to kidnap them and they're out
there the next day protesting it again
no not the next day afterwards literally
same day
hours hours hours afterwards
every single democratic political leader
needs to be asked whether they disavow
this it doesn't matter exactly what
they're doing what's the point of that
they know what's the point of asking it
right do you think there's going to be a
democrat voter somewhere who's going to
be like i'm so surprised they supported
the thing i protested at that is a true
statement you know
there's there's no negotiating
maybe there are some regular people who
don't know all right we're driving in
the car with my buddy who doesn't pay
attention that much and i and i pick up
my phone i'm scrolling to twitter and i
go so there was a child drag show in
texas right and then he goes what
and then i was like what i was like well
that wasn't the point i was trying to
make i was gonna say they were
protesters
but yeah you didn't know it's like what
do you mean child drag shows i'm like
these are happening all over the place
but they don't know what i mean but i
mean and so even i mean to go back to
the yesterday the the lawsuit that we've
we are waging against the these books
that are in schools that are sexually
explicit a lot of parents who has have
kids in schools they don't know that
these books are in there so here's the
issue i'm getting to with this
watching these hearings
the people who are watching it if
someone asks them do you disavow this
the people at home the cognitive
dissonance the zombified democrat people
are going to be like
you you're you're in the other tribe you
want bad thing
you want i agree with a certain
percentage but part of the reason the
left has been effective in their tactics
is because whenever they believe they
have found a reason to shame you they
hit you over the head with it over and
over and over and over again and so i
think it is an effective it's not just
an effective technique i think it's the
right thing to do to say hey do you do
you support this do you disavow this do
you have any kind of leg to stand on
when you talk about insurrection or
political violence or stability or
anything along those lines i think it's
a reasonable question and they do need
to be asked yeah i want to i want to
go ahead no doesn't say if if if at the
other side that if the democrats aren't
willing to speak against this then they
shouldn't speak into january 6. i want
to call it this tweet from jack the
sobek oh i just want to make one more
point if they refuse to condemn
something like this it just totally
undermines their credibility with the
center if there was any that they had
left with the center obviously they're
political bases there's no center the
center is right-wing i think there are
some number of people who would say like
oh i think january 6th was serious or an
insurrection or they don't know any
better but they would not be on board
with a commission led by people who are
okay with assassin's creed i think tim's
right there isn't a center anymore
because they're calling you an extremist
they're calling me right the left is joe
rogan is right wing yes so so not only
is there no center but even center
leftists are right wing now right yeah
that that so let me let me pull this
from jack fasobic yes important he
tweets hi simon gwen why did you delete
this huh and this is a tweet from a uh
let's see simon let's get let's pull up
his profile what we got here he's a
ukrainian flag so he's trying training
he supports current things he tweeted
interesting real-life trolley problem in
america now if you had the chance to
kill clarence thomas or samuel alito the
two oldest right-wing supreme court
judges should you do it while biden can
get his nominees to replace them
confirmed that racism it's an
interesting as an abstract question but
becomes a real conundrum of say you're
terminally ill and have little to lose
yourself
he's basically trying to incite someone
these people are insane they have
celebrated this stuff we need more than
ever you know people to back off yeah to
stop
they're not they're not being held
accountable for it there's no law
enforcement going after them you're
literally advocating hate crime let me
tell you something
uh we had a a tweet from keemstar do you
guys know keemstar earlier keemstar is a
drama alert on youtube
apparently there was some dude who made
a joke about doxing someone at youtube
so they demonetized his channel took
away all of his revenue what had
happened was and this is just for me
watching a keemstar video so i don't you
guys fact check it but there's some
relevance here
he says
this guy got doxxed
he reached out to youtube and said hey
look someone published my private
information youtube said too bad so then
he made a joke saying oh okay so i guess
it's okay i could dox you right they
went boom demonetized his channel wow
what what ethan uh what's uh keemstar
then brings up is ethan klein
saying that he knows for a fact that
there were youtube employees at the nra
convention that ethan klein called to
bomb so ethan klein the host of the h3
podcast comparable size to this show
called on people to commit an act of
terror
before very quickly walking it back
saying okay i got a little passionate
there got a little passionate
all that happened was a strike keemstar
said why would one guy get his entire
channel purged of all monetization
abilities
but ethan klein can call for a terror
attack right and all he gets is a strike
well that raises a question that i
wanted to raise sorry before we move on
we were talking about how this guy who
came to the to kavanaugh's house how did
he know where to go oh right because
they put directions to kavanaugh's house
on social media why is that still up why
is ethan klein allowed to call for an
actual terror attack and they allow it
they they took the video down they did
suspend him that's true they gave he was
passionate he was passionate that's true
but he also probably had any creativity
he wasn't just it wasn't just that he
said i was just joking he also told
people to take guns
yeah go outside the home of a governor
and fire them into the air which is just
insane
seem to believe that an air 15 is fully
auto because when he said to get your
ar-15s and fire him he went
like is he like he thought it was full
auto and then when i guess his producer
said no no that's dangerous you can't do
that comes bolts come down he goes well
blanks then blanks are fine right and
it's like either way the dude actively
called for his audience to commit acts
of uh um
assault with deadly weapons wow and what
happened a single strike
a single strike alex jones got banned
from youtube for making a metaphor about
battle rifles well would i be safe in
assuming that the address for
kavanaugh's house is still up on the
protesters like on the pretty sure it is
yeah it's still up on their organizers
page how is that legal how is that legal
i have no idea yeah i got fully
demonetized for years for i don't know
what just doing what i'm doing here on
this show talking about curt
issues you did confront the ceo of
google yes
he wasn't really happy but that's
another thing luke's uh i was asking did
you know luke's been to epstein island
no how was that
we're back in this conundrum yeah good
work how do i explain this
so so the first time i brought it up
luke didn't catch
what it sounds like it sounds like he
was invited there yeah like i was one of
the you know pervy presidents or you
know
tech guys that you know ceos that was
heading there and no no no i i crashed
it afterwards and he did some
investigation yeah
so after it was already cleared out he
got in a boat and did some investigation
there but likely story yeah
luke just happened to have old footage
he was like how do i convince people i
wasn't really
i take it back you can't be president
yeah
okay so but seriously in in all reality
why why are we at a spot as a nation
that even that joke
has some some truth to it like come on
man because maxwell was convicted no i
know it's just it's so sad that that's
where we're at it really is i think it's
funny that there was a poll
and it was like 57 of republicans
believe that the the country is being
run by a cabal of pedos or whatever
and i'm just like i mean the epstein
thing is proven to be real right like
i'm not surprised people are like bill
clinton flew on that plane and then they
believe that
it's it's it
what are they trying to claim with these
with you know with these news stories
it's kind of hard to deny it honestly
there's no transparency
there's no there's nothing about that
trial and it's only scratching the
surface right this is what we know
publicly still majority of that is still
behind the scenes it's still held in
secret it's still classified
the documents have been sealed in that
case right so there is still it's sealed
because the judge said some of the
details here are so shocking and
salacious the general public can't see
this this is this is what the judge
ruled in that specific case so you could
only imagine this is what we're we're
getting from the outside point of view
only one percent of the of what is
really happening but nobody's standing
outside of that judge's house
and protesting that's very true or or
demanding for those documents to be
unsealed or for the information to make
public light or for those victims to
truly get justice for all of the
horrible things that they have to go
through while of course police officers
judges prosecutors f the fbi
intelligence agencies were all looking
the other way that's another aspect of
this that really should make you wonder
and it's you know what's happening right
now is is just the epitome of not
holding power to account and this is
what happens this is routinely what
happens when you allow people to get
away with these things they're going to
try to get away with bigger and bigger
things uh as time goes on and i think
this is the phase that we're in right
now an extremely dangerous phase for
everyone and how is it a political issue
that's the thing i don't understand when
people are hurting little kids and
you're sexually exploiting little kids
how is this a partisan issue this should
be a human issue the left look i see
these memes all day on facebook they're
saying things like republicans don't
want anyone to know that some people
have two dads and i'm like i'm pretty
sure republicans are mad that the book
they're getting challenged has a picture
of adult you know activities with one
person you know going down and they're
like what
and i'm like okay dude if you get your
news from memes on facebook you're
probably going to be misinformed 100
they they they genuinely believe that
republicans are complaining because a
book showed a kid with two deads and i'm
like well look some sure yeah but are
you going to single out that or are you
gonna focus on what the news story is
actually about the book genderqueer i
was like
if you look at loudoun county they're
talking about a book that shows a white
hand from white person with a devil tale
coming out demonizing white people
outright i'm like yeah i'm i'm not
surprised that people are upset about
racism
but you didn't actually read anything
you just believe whatever rachel maddow
says right so you have no idea what's
going on and their issues so for for us
those two books that we've put forth in
this lawsuit only thing we're asking for
is parental consent parental consent for
parents
for for
minors to view sexually explicit
material very simple restoring parental
rights that's all the problem is is that
these two books
are really pg compared to some of the
other books that are in in circulation
in the public schools i mean there are
books in schools that
have a six-year-old girl
bound and gagged and gang-raped
like this this is in the public school
system but people are acting like it's
not a big deal have you ever read
stephen king
i mean stephen king should we give that
to sixth graders though probably not
well i i honestly
i don't know do schools have stephen
king novels in their libraries too
maybe not i mean because they're adult
they're polygraphic but i don't i don't
you know what's funny is most people
have seen his movies they've not read
his books right
yo
if you read those stories you're gonna
be like uh hold on there a minute i
can't get into them they're way too dark
for me it's not about the well i mean
yeah it's like
most people don't realize that there's a
lot of graphic uh adult scenes among
children in those books
another reason not to like it yeah i
remember i
remember people
you're not selling it for me that's
disgusting i remember people mentioning
that after it came out is that the case
with is that like i mean regardless
disgusting i didn't know that that was
uh a theme with the rest of his oh yeah
that's the thing looks that is so yeah
yeah i just don't understand how that
well i get actually given the behavior
of the fbi i do understand how that
flies that's a theme and you watch
stephen king on twitter and you're like
oh yeah this all makes sense here's the
issue though if you look at throughout
throughout human history societies fall
civilizations fall when when they're
paying their military the least
entertainment the most and they're
focused on sexuality you look at over
and over again these are some of the key
issues that revolve around some
civilizations falling and look at where
we're at as a nation we really have the
degradation and destruction of
civilization usually has these final
steps i i i saw a meme out there with a
child talking to the the dog people who
were dressed in their full fetish
behaviors and uh you know the meme read
this is this is how civilizations
collapse
correct yeah it's disgusting well think
i mean think about it right you look at
the
the left's entire mission and it has
been for decades um if not centuries is
to just break down all sexual morality
and what taboos are left there right
what taboos have yet to be broken down i
kind of those are the ones that they're
going to try to do away with i'm sorry
it's been their mission it's look at
alfred kinsey the one thing the one
thing that all of these
these cultural shifts they're trying to
push have in common is less children
every single one for one they're
outright saying don't have kids the
environment right then they're saying
they're they're encouraging activities
that don't result in having kids they're
encouraging abortion they encourage
meaningful sex it's not all bad birth
control tell kids you know birth control
and condoms and prophylactics and all
that stuff i those are fine but all of
it
it's like hey all of these things result
in less kids
the child transitioning
less kids sterilization of the
sterilization of an entire generation
yeah
that's potentially yeah the birth
control thing should also be talked
about uh skeptically because there is
some data and science coming out that is
very troubling surrounding that
specifically
yeah we uh we mass medicate young girls
yeah that's what their whole mess with
their hormones from their teeth that
they can't go back from yeah create
damages that are there with them for the
rest of their lives well yeah playing
hormone block putting people in hormone
blockers and they act like it's
reversible it's not it's not yeah and
then you look at contraceptives in
general and the idea that you would take
this profound and beautiful human
interaction which creates new life and
totally shift the cultural understanding
of it as this is just something that's
for fun right and it's i mean no wonder
well the
societal breakdown and it's also
interesting because our society is
totally two-faced with it right it's
like have sex have sex have sex have sex
never have children ever have children
never have children well i'm sorry one
leads to the other it's very it's like
do not the way they're telling you to do
it yeah that's right no i i understand
that every push results in less kids
yeah yeah there you go and and it's no
surprise i mean people like bill gates
he did a ted talk on this he said we
need to reduce population growth well
it's no surprise then that he and many
other support programs that re result
either it reminds me that simpsons
episode where they remember that joined
the navy thing yes when they play the
boy band song yeah during the boy band
it's ivan at niosh and then the
recruiter is explaining to lisa how he
does it he's like we do he's like
subliminal liminal and super liminal and
she's like super liminal and he goes
yeah and he opens the window hey you
join the navy and then lenny and carl
are like all right
and then later you see him getting on
the bus like that's all it took that's
what i feel like you've got the the
subliminal which is the you should be on
birth control you know having kids a
nightmare don't have kids where they
outright are just saying like oh it's
bad it's worse just have fun and engage
in these lifestyles then you have the
super liminal which is just outright
being like the environment is hurting
and it's your fault for having kids so
don't have kids and then you have the
kind of unconscious uh chemical
castration of individuals as even some
fish off the coast of florida were found
to have antidepressants within their
system because the the pills the big
pharma are never truly dealt with
they're just kind of pushed on into a
different kind of
in different kind of environment where
you know fish take them we eat the fish
we get affected by these specific big
pharma pills that there's no getting rid
of that's another aspect of it well you
know historically obviously you had you
know classes of people who didn't have
children but generally at least in the
west and in christendom those people
were celibate and they were focused on
other things they were contributing in
really serious and significant ways now
what we're doing is is we're ensuring
that virtually all of the population
either doesn't have children or they
don't have children at replacement rate
and we just keep them distracted with
non-procreative sex and whatever new
gadget comes out that they want to buy
and so it's not as if the energy that
would be expended towards having
children and raising a family is placed
into some other arena which is
productive for the culture society as a
whole it's all just thrown in to seeking
base pleasure right which is why i mean
so for me moving forward one of the
things that i'm i'm passionate about
focusing on is protecting the family
unit i think the family units i mean it
is the basic building block of society
and we have to protect the family unit
yeah well and you mentioned this right
one of the signs of a declining society
is this obsession with sex and part of
the reason that there has to be this
obsession is so you can break down the
barriers because the sex is the building
block of the family which is the
building block of the society and if you
can corrupt the understanding of that
you can tear everything else down i want
to jump to this uh this tweet here and
talk about the next uh story in the
crumbling of society
james woods real james was on twitter
says to the whiners who criticized a
defender ending the deadly threat in a
previous video here's an example of the
consequences of being defenseless to
today's predators you choose
this is a viral video it's a story from
uh just uh i think a few weeks ago
a woman worked at a cell phone store and
a man walked in
and she said how can i help you and he
said do you have
and then just started brutally beating
her and i believe trying to kill her
yeah he was stomping as hard as he could
on her head she escaped she was
seriously hurt
we have this story from the daily mail
shocking moment thugs exchanged gunfire
on busy new york city street in the
middle of the day repeated gang members
shot in the shoulder as an unidentified
gunman remains on the loose then we have
this one
nypd hunt for two thugs after 61 year
old man is sucker punched and killed
while walking down a brooklyn street
near his home police investigating
possible drug robbery
punched him in the face one time and he
was dead yeah that's all it takes that's
why that woman in the first video is is
absolutely lucky to still be alive the
damages that she sustained will probably
be with her for a very long time might
be with her for the rest of her life
when you stomp someone on the ground on
their head so many people die from that
from physical altercations and and the
one thing but the issue here is the
crime itself not the the attack is one
attack what i'm trying to bring up is
in all of these
major cities in new york especially
crime has been insane we had that young
woman on the upper west side walking
home when a bunch of young boys just
stabbed her to death right she tried
running she escaped they grabbed her
again and just started stabbing her
again homicides in san francisco went up
11 it's almost like if you uh advocate
for defunding the police that crime will
go up
i think what we're seeing is a
demoralization
the good cops were quitting yeah but
also the cities themselves are just
breaking down for a variety of reasons
the increases in crime is due to a lot
of things yeah it's it's it's due to
these da's that won't prosecute
that's why chester boudin or however
constance's name is it got recalled
because people were like well they won't
do anything about it back to the streets
right it's all in the name of this woke
equity being fair and just i mean like
this you have some of these people who
have been caught committing the crime
and they're letting them go and a lot of
these criminals know that they could
beat someone up they get hurt they could
do whatever they want to the population
there because they can't defend
themselves in new york city almost every
common sense form of self-defense is is
not allowed whatever tools you could
have to to protect yourself you can't
have in new york city so a lot of people
are talking about poverty a lot of
people are talking about single parent
homes here i i think the the true
problem is i mean
how do you quantify this what how can
you blame it on one particular thing
when it's so many other issues coming
together for this kind of larger
eruption of violence that there's no
going back from no you're absolutely
right but i also think that it's it
comes back down to the base thing we no
longer value human life you don't look
at somebody and they have value so i
mean as a as a as a christian certain as
an ordained minister i look at somebody
they have value because they created the
image of god so you have value just
because you're a human being we don't
have that anymore that we're moving so
far away from that as a society that we
no longer value somebody exactly well
absolutely we're not taught to value
other people in a very bizarre
narcissistic way we're sort of taught to
value ourselves everything is me me me
me and do whatever you want or need to
do to get what is going to be
pleasurable for you right but there's
never any emphasis put on caring for
other people ever and so when somebody
does end up you know
you mention poverty and how people will
bring that up and poverty is not really
the best explanation because
there are people in there even
no no i i no no i'm not saying that
that's an explanation you would argue is
is the case or tells the full story but
there are many cultures and even entire
civilizations which are radically
impoverished compared to our extremely
wealthy and abundant society and they
are not
acting like barbarians in stabbing you
know children are not running around
stabbing women and men are not beating
up old men on the street or you know
going into places of business and just
savagely beating innocent women right
aoc we have the story from july of 2020
when she defends the rise in crime
saying people are stealing bread to feed
their children during record
unemployment the aoc it's like
people were getting shot in the streets
and she was like they're trying to steal
bread and it's like
they just shot a guy in front of his
daughter they didn't take anything from
her there's no bread there
we're not complaining about the bread
theft no
and though and here's the thing too man
that the media allows these radical left
people and really all politicians but
we see the radical lying to the american
people over and over and over again and
there's no accountability none so we're
not holding people accountable you're
not holding politicians accountable
you're not holding people accountable
law and orders just out the window this
is society falls like this this is
exactly how society falls i think it's
uh weak men make hard times
what we're seeing is you know you guys
are basically saying it no one cares for
each other there's no sense of community
no because everyone feels like everyone
else is just out to get them or for them
or or get for themselves so they're just
like
you know you see these cops in uvalde
and i these cops refuse to go in and i'm
just like because they're think they're
not thinking about their community or
the betterment of civil civilization
they're thinking me
well that or or it's a it's a breakdown
of leadership too uh so i mean i i know
law enforcement's in my community and
one of the things that they said was uh
the people inside uh standing in the
stack were actually listening to their
commanding officer who said don't go in
that it shifted but they were an active
shooter it shifted from an active
shooter to a hostage situation so their
their protocol was very different but
that information is not true with the
over overwhelming amount of evidence
coming forward right now they knew it
was an active shooter they had all the
evidence it was an active shooter and
they were already inside of that school
and then they just left and abandoned
those children there so that's another
aspect
it was reported they could hear the
children getting shot yeah it was
reported that i'm not giving an excuse
for i'm just saying that's that's what i
i that's their public explanation that
they've been lying
they've been lying through their teeth
though from the beginning of this
it's crazy i mean all on
the interesting story in that to me and
all of that is is you're like one mom
was arrested put in handcuffs she got
out of release from the handcuffs jumped
the fence jumped the fence rescued their
two kids they came back i mean yeah and
she reported how there was active
gunshots when the police were telling
everyone that it was there was no
accident a father went in with a shotgun
you could hear it you could hear the
guns yeah well it was a father and a
team that went down with him with the
shield right and then went and took out
the threat after disobeying orders and
finally uh doing you know the thing that
they should have been doing from the
very beginning but that man also waited
over 30 plus minutes short scene so
it's a long time it's great you're
hearing shooting and you're
and you're seeing that situation and
people are just waiting but calling for
a change in legislation and calling for
more legislation as a result it just
isn't the right answer because if if
legislation was actually what fixed it
it wouldn't happen to start with there's
multiple laws broken you can't fix
cultural problems with policy nope and i
don't see us
finding i don't see there being a way to
fix our cultural problems well i mean
and you also got to realize too i think
and i think i said it yesterday we could
never allow times of tragedy to dictate
policy
because every time you do that you're
just opening up the future opportunity
for people to actually create the
tragedy to strip you of whatever rights
or freedoms you want next i think oh
that's this is what's happening with the
gun control debate yeah totally it's
like we're all shocked so we're saying
do something do what do something if you
don't have a plan
the meme is keep calm and carry on not
freak out and just do something right no
do something is not always the answer
thomas macy had some very good tweets
about the legislation that they're
proposing and the counter evidence to it
on his public twitter account that i
think is uh worth considering and
looking at especially when it comes to
the latest political debates surrounding
this uh very hot button issue um and and
he made a lot of very good points
so um
well if you look at so historically
while you're looking at it so
historically look at prior to 1970 there
wasn't a decade if i if my numbers are
right there's not a decade there was
more than 10 mass shootings okay so i
think in 1950 there was one 1960 there
was six 1970s 13 i think it was 32 and
42. so to me i always want to look at
what's the root cause the root cause
around all of that was a absolutely a
cultural shift so like in 62 63 they
took prayer and bibles out of schools
and 70s that was when roe v wade
happened so you're having all this stuff
going on with abortions so as a society
our values shifted drastically to that
time it's it's not actually this late
60s and 70s it's the generation before
because
the boomers were raised by a generation
right they they had those values once
they grew up they enacted those values
what we're seeing now with millennials
in wokeness were values instilled in
them when they were like 10. right i
remember being young having all of the
teachers talk about you know racism
being bad and civil rights and we had to
learn the true history of civil rights
and everything
well for them
the older generation that raises us they
live through it they experience say oh i
get it
you then raise a younger generation on
telling them you must fight racism what
happens when they grow up and most of
these policies have already been made
illegal
they're looking for it as hard as they
can because they were raised in this
world
one of the things that really impacted
everybody
was uh imagine you're 10 years old in
2008
and uh you're on facebook well let's say
2012. let's say 10 years ago you're 10
years old say you're eight years old
and on facebook all you're seeing are
videos of police brutality yeah
because that was making people money and
the algorithm kept promoting it yep
if that's the only thing you see your
whole world growing up yeah from eight
to 18 was watching videos of police
brutality you turn 18 and you're
freaking out you're like i have to vote
to stop this
their whole world is guaranteed
police are hunting black people
right like yo calm down dude but the
reality is the vast majority of all law
enforcement are great people
they're willing to put themselves
between you and any self anybody that
wants you harm wants to wish you harm
and that's that's a huge thing we have
to advocate for our police gen z is
going to be the algorithm generation
millennials grew up half and half when
we were young we didn't we had the
internet but we didn't have these
algorithms we get into our you know
early 20s or whatever late 20s and now
we have these these algorithms
manipulating our views but half of our
lives are still built upon the previous
non-social media infrastructure
gen z is basically growing up in
algorithmic and algorithmic world their
adult lives are all algorithmic
alpha 100 of it is right so their worlds
are all going to be completely
controlled by the whims of mark
zuckerberg and jack dorsey and and
youtube yep
when
the boomers
and the gen xers age out this country is
going to go into full-on conflict or
chaos violence
just you name it
it'll be interesting to see the shift
there'll definitely be a shift um but i
actually think that i actually think the
way especially right now it's radical as
because the left isn't no longer they're
not liberals
are no liberals they're now radicals are
running the democrat party right so i
actually think that they're going to
create a generation of truly
conservative people well that's that's
what i believe maybe i think the bigger
issue is that conservatives have kids
and the left doesn't and if the left
doesn't win the fight but it's true i
mean scientifically that's very true if
the left doesn't win the fight in
schools then they are gone right like
literally within a couple generations
and people are pulling their kids out of
school right they're putting them in
private school or going home school
which i would i would advocate for this
is it right here if if you homeschool
your kids that's it
if every single
post liberal moderate centrist
libertarian conservative said i'm gonna
homeschool my kids within three
generations all the left is gone
oh yeah completely so what people don't
understand
these big shifts you mentioned like in
the 70s with roe v wade what's really
happening is that
power is held by people in society that
power is used to control and spread
messages or enact policy
typically the older generation controls
a disproportionate amount of wealth
right now boomers control more wealth
than uh the previous generation did when
they were the same age as millennials
basically
millennials should be holding i think
like 20 or 30 of wealth they hold like
three
boomers hold like 25 or something i was
reading some report on this
what's going to happen is
boomers are going to slowly start dying
they're getting old
when they do
that wealth and power will transfer to a
millennial or to a gen xer probably from
a boomer to a to a millennial maybe some
younger zenial types people who are in
their early 40s
when that starts happening that power
will be wielded as per the ideology of
the younger people and these younger
people according to the splc favor
political assassinations more so
so if a billion dollars is held by
someone who's 80 years old they're not
going to be spending it towards
extremism right if they die and that
wealth transfers to their five young
heirs who are more likely to believe in
violence that wealth will now be
utilized in that direction it's not that
a society over time decides like a lot
of people think that there's a guy named
bob
and bob one day turns on the youtube and
goes wow i have been radicalized and
then grabs a tiki torch and goes outside
what really happens is that bob sees the
youtube videos and goes wow that's crazy
and then bob tells his kid and he says
you see this stuff man life shouldn't be
this way then that kid grows up grabs a
tiki torch and goes outside right it's
when the older generation dies off that
that shift we see isn't that society has
decided something like a person's mind
changed it's that the people of certain
values no longer live and the power
transfers to those of different ideas
yep that's why i advocate for values
values exactly faith family freedom
these are the three things that i think
that are that are building blocks for
our society historically it's what made
us a great nation we come back to those
things i really do believe that's the
hope for our future is there any way to
politically achieve those how would what
kind of things would you propose
legislation or action plans that would
help uh bring that forward well first i
mean i do i would absolutely put forth
legislation codifying parental rights
saying that parents have rights of their
children's medical and education
decisions and in that
in that i think that the money for
education should follow the student so
whether a parent decides they're going
to go to public school they're going to
private school they're going to
homeschool whatever that money is that
goes to those students that credit goes
to that student yeah new hampshire
already does this it should i mean it
should be federally yeah i mean
federally that should happen if we're
going to put money in to the government
because we want to take care of the
education of our children they should
follow our kids wherever they go of
course that makes sense to me well
donald trump proposed the voucher system
right yeah voucher is great i absolutely
agree with 100 i don't know if it's the
you know the true uh like the one
solution to helping kids with schools
and fixing the school problems
but i mean dissolving the department of
education and pushing that down to the
state levels is a huge start yes yeah
yeah also i mean look it's not just the
fact that children would no longer be
indoctrinated in the same way if parents
had any choice about where they could
send their children to school children
to school but also we would probably end
up achieving at a higher level with
respect to education generally speaking
if schools had to compete for students
and so what the left will say when they
argue against uh school choice and this
is such an unbelievable self-owned but
they'll say you only advocate for school
choice because you want to bankrupt
public schools all right well you're
admitting parents would send their kid
anywhere else if they had a choice yeah
the public schools are that bad make
them better exactly so it's like well
school choice wouldn't be a threat if we
had public schools which were decently
run and you wanted to put the effort
into making them function decently
parents should have a choice for their
kids
public schools are a net negative on
your children yeah 100 parents don't
want their children indoctrinated
they want your child they we want our
children to be educated the basics you
know what
reading writing and arithmetic i mean
stem studies these are the basic things
that we want for our kids we don't want
them indoctrinated growing up honestly i
mean i did not know where most of my
teachers landed politically
and that's how it should be
you're there to teach me a subject and
that's it help me learn let me learn how
to learn
rather than just shoving something down
my throat that's what we want for our
kids we don't want them indoctrinated
but that's what's happening it is that
100 what's that happening and for a lot
of people it's not as easy to just get
your kids out of school because no it's
expensive well it's basically daycare
right well yeah there is that but it's
also expensive
all of these things are you know
connected to each other when women enter
the workforce
at first it was
you can work if you want to which is
true and correct equal opportunity but
then all of a sudden the workforce
doubles
and now
some guy goes to apply for a job and the
boss says
look this guy over here he's got a wife
who's working he doesn't need as much
money right i'm not going to pay you
what you're asking for and the guy says
okay i'll go down now all of a sudden
the guy comes home and says honey i got
the job
bad news you need to start working
because we're not gonna have enough
money right now she's working who's
raising the kids they gotta go to
daycare fortunately public schools they
can drop their kids off and say someone
else will take care of it the more
workers the more you're able to pay them
less because there's more competition
for that market and this is why uh you
know there's individuals like david
rockefeller that were huge proponents of
of this larger movement when it came to
allowing women to to to work because he
knew that it would allow him and his
factories and his businesses to earn a
lot more money and i think that's
another aspect to really understand here
especially with his kind of formation of
the education system that we're under
right now what we what we need is pod
schooling yes you know i hear it's we
were talking with one of our guests that
was not that easy but uh women can and
should be at work if they want to be i
think equal opportunity is fantastic and
then your kids if you need someone to
watch them you shouldn't put them in an
institutionalized learning facility
where you don't know the teachers you
should get someone you know and trust
have them come together for your
community and teach this you know this
one person can do it all i want to i
just want to make this point there's a
great quote from chesterton he said that
feminism is the modeled idea that women
are free when they serve their employers
and slaves when they serve their
husbands
yeah and i wanted to say it is correct
that women should be allowed to do
whatever they want but i think that the
cultural imperative right now is that
women should want to be cogs in the
machine like chesterton talks about
they're told that they should want to
serve an employer not be a slave to
their children and you can listen to the
narrative that moms nowadays have about
their kids they're like i can't stand
being around my kids i can't imagine how
you home school i'm so glad when they
leave for the day and it's like why did
you have children what was your thinking
you obviously aren't in the right
mindset to be like okay i want to raise
kids here's what i'm going to do it's
really important to bring them up
correctly they just hand them off to the
nearest person which tends to be the
state it's a huge problem i hate the
mindset and i hate that that culture has
made it so that women are incentivized
to leave their families and go back to
work we don't see children as a gift
anymore either you know i mean one of my
honestly one of my favorite things is
being a father you know i really see
once a great responsibility to raise up
a human being to take over into society
but
to me i think that we have to see
children as a gift that's what they are
that is the next generation that's who's
going to take over the country he's
going to take over the world
it's a it's such a huge responsibility
but a huge privilege to get to raise
somebody and teach them and guide them i
got an idea for a form of government
where the law is applied to you as you
wish it to be applied to others that's
it
simple there you go yeah so if you're
someone who's like i i think violence is
wrong then if someone commits violent to
get violence against you then you that
person will be criminally charged if you
commit violence against someone else you
will be criminally charged if someone
else say like an antifa person says well
i believe it's justified then someone
comes and fights you we we there's no
law to be applied because you don't find
a problem with it
right i mean i'm half kidding but you
get the idea right yeah it's interesting
good i know i just wanted to piggyback
on something you said because you know
you're a father you have children i
don't but one thing that i have always
found very sad about this culture is
just the way having children is viewed
it's strange because people will point
out that having kids is hard work and
then they'll say therefore it's not
worth it but we don't really do that
with anything else i mean we're starting
to in some areas but imagine like well i
don't want to become rich because being
rich is hard work only suckers do hard
work but that's basically the attitude
that our society has cultivated when it
comes to children it's like right well
it's it's hard work so screw that why do
it but it's that is actually that does
carry over to everything i think it
started to so i've seen it so as a small
business owner i've had so many people
go oh man you're really lucky what do
you mean really lucky yeah sacrificed
years of my life do you know me do you
know me how much times i miss with my
parents with my kids or even my parents
how much time i've missed with my family
in order to be able to and luckily we do
a lot of it together as a family you
know as far as building out our studio
and everything else but there are some
things you're just going to spend time
away from your family in order to do it
so it's not just this oh you just get it
so but people aren't willing to do the
hard work same thing with kids though
it's they're seen as a sacrifice oh
that's all i'm gonna have to give up
what are you talking about this is such
a gift that you get to have
influence in somebody else's life and
you get to guide them in life it's such
a good and think about once they're you
know like nine years old and they can
start washing the dishes that's great
that's right i remember the first time
that my oldest son cut the grass i took
a picture i sent it to my dad i was like
oh this is what it was all about he's
like you made it son
[Laughter]
whenever i see someone work really hard
at something i admire it and so like as
someone without kids when i see someone
with kids who's working hard to raise
them what it says to me is if they're
willing to put that kind of effort in it
must really be worth it it is but for
whatever reason
we don't look at things that way anymore
we see someone putting hard work and we
go oh they're a sucker they're putting
hard work in instead of saying well
maybe they're putting hard work and
because there's a significant reward
here there's something bigger than this
they're missing out another huge problem
with the millennial generation and
younger is the entitlement sure no no no
hard work i hear it all the time if only
i had x then i could do it if only i had
money and i'm just like
wow as an employer i can tell you that
that's true yeah you know i mean and and
i value somebody that's willing to do
the hard work i tell my boys all the
time i said listen in the future when
you're in the working class
if you will show up on time
just simply do your job and have a good
attitude you'll be a superstar
yep that's it you don't don't ask for
anything extra don't do it if you just
simply do those things you'll be a
superstar because well right now people
don't want to work and they're being
incentivized by the government whether
it's state or federal
to stay at home it's a huge problem
that's the decline of society they're
being told that they're entitled to
things right the the fascinating thing
to me is bernie sanders health care is a
human right it's like you know health
care is labor from another person right
you have no human right to someone
else's labor that's called slavery right
and
i i hate hearing this idea of socialized
healthcare i so look at being a disabled
veteran i have socialized healthcare
it's called the va it sucks most of us
actually opt out and pay for private
healthcare because it's so bad so this
idea that socialized healthcare it
sounds great socialism sounds great on
well in theory but in practice it's
horrible but he doesn't talk about the
laziness of human beings this is the
issue of bernie sanders what he has
called for is not been done anywhere as
far as as far as i understand abolishing
private insurance and only allowing
government medic medical care which is
nuts in most other countries they have
government basic health care and then
you can buy private as well on top which
is you get your private if you want it
right or you can have the public if
you're if you can't afford it what for
some reason in the us they're like ban
private healthcare and so they will do
this sleight of hand where when they
refer
to universal health care they'll usually
use that phrase interchangeably with
single-payer and then they'll say oh all
over europe they have universal
healthcare but they don't have a
single-payer system author europe like
true single-payer systems are actually
relatively rare most of the countries
that we really look up to the left looks
up to and wants to emulate have a sort
of a public private hybrid system or a
system where it's private insurance but
it's mandated
sanders proposal for universal health
care is like by the lowest possible
estimates and these are almost according
to people who came up with these numbers
too low to be realistic they're being
generous right but it would cost 32
trillion over 10 years which is about
like 75
of
our current level of federal spending
it's just it's not economically feasible
and i say this because when i've pointed
this out people when i've pointed this
out people have said well if that's true
how do they have single payer and all
these other cards they don't they do not
have single-payer all three years i'm
sorry well that's not true but aoc said
just print the money
oh i forgot that doesn't that's what's
so okay this is what's so funny is now
bernie sanders is not the radical in his
party yeah yeah that's where they're at
now that's what's crazy but let's go
back to uh the family unit you know we
don't talk we don't advocate for the
family unit anymore no you don't hear
politicians advocate for the family unit
anymore we've got to get back to that i
really believe that as a as a legislator
there's three things i have to protect
you have to fight to protect the family
unit personal property and the religious
institutions those things are pillars in
our society it makes a well-functioning
society and i know that not everybody is
religious but the reality is that our
founding fathers while all of them were
not christians they believed applying
biblical principles to a society made a
more well-functioning society well this
is an interesting interesting thing that
we talk about every so often
that uh bill maher is my favorite
example
his his moral foundations are all
christian
but he is one of these staunchest
atheists you'll ever meet sure he
talked he made the religious religious
documentary he says he doesn't believe
in all the fairy tales but the things
that he espouses free speech
you know uh innocent until proven guilty
are are based in the in the christian
moral framework absolutely you have
people in this country who grew up
raised by christians
but they say i don't believe these
things you know you know let me give a
shout out to one of my favorite songs of
all time and it's judith by a perfect
circle and i just recently i haven't
heard it in like a decade you know the
song
so uh a perfect circle is absolutely
fantastic big fan and this song is just
one of the most well-written songs and
you read the lyrics and they're
incredible
the story is about the lead singer his
mother had a stroke but she never
stopped uh
praising you know the lord and being
religious and it's him saying like i
never want to be like you you've never
stopped to question why he did this to
you and you have faith in him and it
sounds like with all due respect he
genuinely doesn't understand faith or
religion right and it's a fascinating
story because either you have this man
who a lot of atheists would probably
look at and be like he's so right his
mom's so ignorant or you have a story
about a woman who after all the
hardships still has faith in her
religion and my view of it is it's such
a weird thing
to be like
he did this to you
instead of thinking it was a
circumstance of the existence that was
created and you are praying for some
kind of you know salvation or whatever
it's just my point here is
i think what ends up happening you have
people who have these moral values
rooted in christianity they have kids
who don't fully grasp or understand it
which in my opinion is the fault of the
previous generation yeah absolutely but
they retain some of the basic values
they learn from their family like
supporting free speech and innocent
until proven guilty right now again i
want to stress i am not religious but
if you look up the history of the fifth
amendment this is literally rooted in
the bible and you can trace it all the
way back i was fascinated by learning
this history
it was uh
it was it was it was codified because of
this idea benjamin franklin said it is
better that 100 guilty persons escaped
than one innocent person suffer right
and that was his take on blackstone's
formulation it is better that 10 guilty
persons escaped than one innocent person
suffer there was a very basic logic
behind it if an individual does not
believe that they will be treated fairly
within a system then their only
incentive is to work against the system
that if you are wrongly accused the
state will seek to punish you and never
seek to protect your innocence why
should you bother playing fairly with
that system blackstone was quite
brilliant but that idea was rooted in
the story of sodom and gomorrah if there
is but one righteous person i will not
destroy this town that came from the
bible whether you like the bible or not
that value if you believe in the
innocent until proven guilty that's
where it comes from you take a look at
the modern left cult and they don't have
any of these moral values right they
believe there's no truth but power they
believe in blank slate they believe the
majority should have you know the
authority and things like that and
that's what a a lack of a moral
framework looks like absolutely i'm not
i'm not i'm not saying here to say
people should be christian i'm not
saying people should believe in god or
that god is real i'm just saying
understand the root of the the basic
moral foundations and the laws of this
country and the constitution so i
studied world religion and one of the
things that i found fascinating um and
it's why you know i have faith in in
jesus as a christian is you study world
religion really religion comes down to
and this is probably not i don't really
talk about but religion comes down to
human beings attempt to earn favor with
the divine
the separation of all that was the
teachings of jesus jesus was the first
person really to advocate for the rights
of women the rights of children like he
talked against the actual the normal
societal framework that they were in
right then it's actually why he was
assassinated it was it was killed
because
he spoke against the religious leaders
and what they had he said he was going i
got to shout something out too
sheamus uh informed me that uh jesus
said if you do not have a sword sell
your cloak and buy one
did you do do you know what passage
that's from and what it's about i could
pull this up yeah i decided to look it
up and you want to know what it is what
is it so i could be wrong about this so
you know you have to factor me on this
one but he was talking with his
followers about how the government
sought to kill him right indeed and he
said what is written about me shall come
to pass right those who has a purse
should take it if you do not have a
sword sell your cloak and buy one the
assessment i read said he was telling
his followers to get armed because the
government was going to try to kill him
intriguing and i laughed when i read
that so i i i try to be very very
careful about like especially public
interpretations of theology because i'm
not like formally theologically
lettered um and a lot of people bring up
well you know he also says he who lives
by the sword dies by the sword point is
in the christian tradition it has not
historically been
pacifistic in the sense that you could
never defend yourself if someone's
trying to harm you i mean this is this
is a modern invention you know i always
love talking about the memes i see on
facebook
and one of them was it was like some
atheist lefty said
jesus said those who live by the sword
die by the sword you know
conservatives should give up their guns
and i was like telling someone that if
you engage in combat with a gun you
could result in in your death is not
telling you not to have one it's warning
you that there are dangers that come
right with exercising this but more
importantly
when when i then tell them like look
again i'm not religious but he literally
said to buy a sword and it was in
reference to
it was written that he would be killed
and so he was like you should have
swords and then someone said i have two
and he says that is exactly enough i'm
like two that's more than one that's a
great start
oh go ahead no there you go well i just
wanted to make this point that it's even
external to like simply being christian
or believing in scripture i'm sure this
is something you've recognized as you
study different world religions and i am
not a pluralist i am not i don't believe
all religions are equally true or
anything along those lines but in every
functioning stable societal system you
have something approximating the ten
commandments right and the scriptures
also say that the ten commandments are
written on the heart of every man this
isn't just something people uh need to
hear from divine revelation so
it's not simply that they reject
christianity they reject any and all
semblance of the moral law or the
natural law what they reject is personal
accountability of any kind well there's
no idea of like personal guilt or i
could have done something wrong and so
when you look at um you know what's
required for for a stable society to
function obviously not murdering not
bearing false witness not committing
adultery because when you commit
adultery who knows who's responsible for
for whose children i mean these things
are completely and entirely instrumental
to having any kind of a stable system
yeah it's kind of interesting i've had
people that have told me you know you
shouldn't run for office because you're
an ordained minister
um and i'm like what are you talking
about like what's the separation of
church and state that's ridiculous
that's not what that's talking about
that's to actually protect people from
the government not to protect the
government from people our founding
fathers never did that with anything
yeah second amendment is a perfect
example of that
i mean that's ex that exists to protect
us from tyranny of government that's
what exists for it in part of why i
bring up the ten commandments is because
so often when christians are refused are
accused of being theocratic or someone
says you're trying to force your
religion to people it's not because a
christian politician is saying we need
to force people to go to church on
sunday it's not because catholics such
as myself are saying oh we need to force
people to do these kinds of penances um
it's because there is some element of
the natural law of the ten commandments
that our society is left behind and
we're simply pointing out that if you
want a functioning system people have to
follow those rules it's beneficial to
have somebody who is in governance that
has a moral framework what we're seeing
in our societies people don't have a
moral framework one thing i've said a
while back is that it feels like
there's a lot of ways people describe
the two factions in politics or the
culture war i've described it as
christian moral framework versus
none
no moral framework right and a lot of
people uh there are a lot of people who
criticize me and say they don't like
that and they're atheists and they're
like i'm an atheist i'm a liberal i've
never believed this stuff and then i
just try and talk to them like where do
you do you believe in the fifth
amendment the right that you're innocent
until proven guilty do you know the
history of this and where it comes from
right again my point is by all means you
don't have to believe in in god and the
bible sure but the morals that this
country had for a long time were built
upon these things and so when that last
line is lost right you get a generation
of people who say what does it matter
i mean our founding fathers said that
that our constitution works for a moral
society yeah well and then again what
constitution doesn't right like what
system works in an immoral society one
argument i remember hearing a lot and
this is even something christopher
hitchens said was you know christians
don't have a monopoly on morality and
hitchens his line was like you expect me
to believe that they uh got all the way
to uh mount sinai and just then learned
that it was wrong to kill and rape and
steal i'm sorry you know when the ten
commandments came down and that bearing
false witness was wrong but the point is
no
no we're not arguing that but what's
ironic is they will point out these
basic moral norms that they say
everyone's familiar with external to
christianity but then whenever any
christian talks about enforcing those
norms they go well that's christian
theocracy you're trying to force your
religion of me hold on i thought these
were things we all agreed on right well
that's that's the funny thing now when
you look at people who don't believe in
free speech yeah right this is why i
start to see
they don't believe in innocent until
proven guilty they believe it is
acceptable to bear false witness they
believe that people should not have a
right to speak and i'm like it's really
really fascinating it's like there's a
new religion right uh it was peter
pagosian james lindsey and helen pluck
rose who did the so-called squared hoax
i went and and we and i interviewed them
james we've had in the show a couple
times peter pagosian talked about
intersectionality as a new non-theistic
religion which is effectively wokeness
right and we had a really interesting
discussion privilege is your original
sin like there's a lot of there's a lot
of facsimiles right where they've tried
to replace these things perhaps people
have something within them where they
they long for purpose i think that's
true yeah and when they lost
the faith or religion and i don't care
what religion it is they're people of
all different religions but when people
don't have one they find one right and
they found wokeness and that's why
they're dogmatic in their approach
that's how they handle it and we can't
find we can't find our purpose in our
religion in politics
that's what we're seeing too is as
that's become the i think the a lot of
the radicals uh treat their their
politics like a faith system and that's
why it's become so toxic i just i
disagree with you guys if you don't
think dr fauci and george floyd aren't
prophets of our modern day right you
guys just blasphemous sicko of the
wokism and corporatism that we're all
living under right now
i have to mention it
when that mural of george floyd was
struck by lightning and exploded
that one freaked me out
i'm always very careful to speak on
behalf of god
but sometimes god speaks for himself
yeah there you go i gotta say that was
that was something else
it was like this whole wall was painted
and lightning struck just the part it's
george floyd the crown on fascinating
well and i mean look that is
that is one of the tenets of the state
religion that has filled the void that
has been well
christian
it's literally corporations and powerful
ruling elites creating the perfect
consumer the perfect individual to be a
slave of their current system that of
course they're building and and and if
you could if you could literally build a
person that that you could you could
suck the life out of suck the wealth out
of suck the potential out of it is the
modern man yeah so i think that's the
value to me that's the value of faith
you know what i mean so i think that
we're losing that as a society so we
don't have a moral framework but the
value of faith is you have
accountability something higher than
yourself
that accountability can't be the
government it can't be that you believe
that the government's here to save you
we've seen time and time again no no no
no no no it's pfizer fighter's gonna
save us they know what's best for us and
they could do no wrong
and uh we should always listen to him
and and uh and lord bill gates and i i
want to make one more point
matt walsh has made headlines with his
fantastic documentary what is a woman
and he's highlighting the absurdity of
the fact that we share a society with
people uh who can't give us an accurate
definition of what a woman is and who we
don't agree on what women is but there's
a problem that goes even deeper which is
that
for decades we have lived in a society
with people who we don't have the same
definition of what man
is right with right so are human beings
made in god's image and likeness or are
we just these self-replicating coils of
dna human yes yes
are we just these sort of genetic
automatons and
just consciousness is
the wet stuff in your head this meat
substance giving rise to information
processing or do we have intrinsic value
i think that's a much more substantial
distinction and it's totally been it's
totally been lost and i think the issue
here we talked about this um you're
projecting
yes how am i projecting is your
projection when someone tells you they
don't have a soul why would you assume
they're wrong they don't because i
believe all humans have a solid well
right you're projecting because you do
and you believe it certainly someone
else must but
i was talking to somebody who was an
atheist and they told me they don't
believe in the soul they don't believe
in the spirit they don't believe in god
or religion and i said so do you think
you're like then what are you what robot
and i'm like i believe you yeah i
personally feel the soul within me i i
have this experience i have this this
this inner inner inner monologue some
people don't have that did you know that
yeah well here's that said to me because
i mean for me i i just see that i just
say look i see the value in recognizing
in a creator and that we all have
origin in that creator and we all have a
soul
so i see value in that i think that
society would see a value in that but i
mean you can't make people to believe
yeah well and the point i would make is
yes you are right there are many people
who say they don't have a soul who say
they don't have free will i don't
believe that makes it so i think by
definition if a person does have a soul
and they do have free will then that
would allow for the possibility of them
to deny that they have a soul and free
will but what if they don't have free
will
i believe that they do what if they're i
understand that this is an argument yes
yes
it's a belief about mankind but it's
also properly basic everyone operates as
if they have free will some deny its
existence but no one acts as if they
don't believe but him projecting his
belief doesn't mean that he's wrong yeah
no i know he just means that i mean
somebody else could say you're wrong i'm
saying but you are projecting your
belief onto other people
my question my my point was simply the
question of what if they're
right what if they're right yeah yeah i
i believe that you have to be humble
enough to realize i could be wrong no
for sure but i think if i'm wrong then
i'm wrong about the fact that i have
free will in a soul like if they're
right then we're all genetic automatons
there's not some special exception for
me because of what i believe no no if
someone is so if within yourself you
feel your existence and you feel your
presence and your soul
someone else could not have one it
doesn't mean you don't
you could have a soul and they might not
some people might be npcs but we would
have to look at the explanation for that
right so their world view is not enough
souls in existence for every human body
maybe we ran out there's there's too
much
someone someone on this show mentioned
there was a philosopher or writer who
said that
there were not enough souls for the
entirety of the bodies that are being
created well then you're denied a
creator yeah in my opinion you in my
opinion you'd be denying a creator if a
creator can create souls and it can
create an infinite amount or the right
amount for the number of people
but what if they the creator just simply
chose not to what if what if the creator
said there's one billion we're done if
you read so if i as i read scripture
that would not be congruent with the
creator described in scripture
let's go to super chat
wait you guys are playing you guys are
playing this video game seriously
that was quite the spiral sorry i i
think my point is just that i think it
takes a lot more intellectual work and
many more assumptions to make the
argument that like some humans don't
have a soul and some some do i really do
believe that the most straightforward
explanation is we all do what we all
don't it has to be universalized
all right let's read these super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel and share the show with your
friends if you do like it head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show coming up at 11 p.m
this time we got you because uh no no
serious threats or anything not yet so
uh sure
we're able to keep working so again
smash that like button and we will now
read your super chats
all right do for you says no chair
equals despair yeah some people were
saying uh that we should have started
the stream empty
[Laughter]
mike scott says tim saw you get angry in
your vid today i've been campaigning for
congress in maryland running as
republican in a solid d most ds aren't
part of the cult and want better just
remember to keep striving for better you
do good work bro
i gotta add over a lot of things today
that uh you know we get we get this
threat jeremy hamilly gets this threat
and then these protesters show up at
kavanaugh's and they won't there's no
justice there is no enforcement of law
in this country anymore yeah you have to
have enforcement there has to be law and
order it's there there are a bunch of
whistleblowers claiming the fbi has been
purging conservative staff members so
clearly what's happening is that this
country is factionalizing and gearing up
for a conflict
all right
raymond g stanley jr says what we all
want to know pierogies or potatoes
pierogies of course
potatoes are great you know i would i
would say pierogies but they're made
with wheat aren't they yeah
they're really good though yeah but
aren't they just potato anyway
they're better potatoes oh you know what
it is good you know it doesn't get
kalachakis yeah they're freaky ooh
kolachi circus yeah yeah
i would agree with you but but a pierogi
is just like a dumpling with potato in
it yeah
so i guess
you still got potatoes what you're
saying is like a plain potato versus
like a fancy one yeah absolutely that's
like that's the difference perfectly
represented here at this table i don't
like it i don't i don't i don't need all
the glitz and glam i haven't tried
substance
it's just a dirty potato
now look i'm not denying that either
both things can be true
valiant thor says everything thomas
sowell said would uh said would continue
to happen is happening much love to you
all and so glad no one was harmed you
handled it with class and resilience as
we will continue to do
jeff pearson says red flag laws equals
legalized swatting that's right mm-hmm
yeah it will
if they pass red flag laws yeah then you
are it's going to be swattings across
the board oh yeah girlfriends and
boyfriends are going to be snitching on
each other because they're mad they
already do yeah yeah yeah yeah so it'll
be it'll be good
family members on every on every
streamer or neighbors not like liking
the other neighbor oh yeah bad
thanksgiving dinner next thing you know
yeah exactly yeah it's a problem
all right johnny boy 291 says tim i've
been watching your videos since he
reports during occupy wall street after
yesterday's situation and your push back
against daryl davis among other recent
events i've finally decided to sign up
for a membership on your website oh
that's fantastic thank you very much
there's another one here it says one out
of two there we go johnny boy says keep
up the good fight brother and keep
speaking out we need more people like
you all out there stay safe guys
so are you familiar with daryl davis no
he's the famous black black black jazz
musician who de-radicalized clan members
simply by befriending them yeah yeah i
do yep i mean i didn't know i couldn't
put a name to the face but yes we had
him on the show and i think what ended
up happening was a lot of people assumed
that because he radicalized clan members
he was anti-identitarian
right so his thing was all you know we
should just be humans together turns out
he's actually very much identitarian he
wants reparations okay he believes in
white privilege and all that kind of
stuff so what a lot of people are
disappointed because it seemed like
there was going to be this prominent
speaker who was like we should all be
people and be friends and race shouldn't
be a factor in this and then it turns
out he actually is still very racist
should have morgan freeman on
yeah i mean that's basically what he was
saying right right you just be people
yep
all right
samuel pyle says the house passed a
federal red flag law today was that
today or was it yesterday it was
yesterday no yeah did they do it today
we talked i'll be surprised
jonathan howe says january 6 hearing
begins tonight oh did it how much you
want to bet they paint us all as
terrorists and use this to demonize
those who won't submit to their
authority that's all it is i mean the
left is using that to to demonize those
who descend that's all it's political
descent
all right
kayla howlett says i love potatoes and i
love sheamus thank you potato man good
apparently famous one luke 0.
all right let's find some good brian
says swap that like button and so i i
actually pinned a another i saw that and
then i pinned and swat the like but i
thought that was funny
dodge gaskill says tim poole and co all
your phones are probably tapped yeah
they were tapped years ago
people like
15 years ago i was like your problems
are tapped everyone's like you're crazy
you're insane the government would never
do that i mean patriot
after after occupy wall street i had an
android and an iphone and i remember one
day they both turned on at the same time
or like like very close the same time
like one turn on the other turned on and
then i was like what their software i
turned them off and they turned right
back on they are spying devices they're
not cell phones they're they're
literally here just to keep track of
everything there's software that
governments buy right that they can turn
your phone on and listen at any time
martin edgar says tim the ryan kelly
thing goes deeper five other gop
candidates were disqualified including
craig who was the front-runner before
his disqualification keep up the great
work tim and crew wow
that's crazy
all right
bad karma says events from yesterday if
a justice is removed from the supreme
court the sitting president gets to
appoint a replacement correct that's
right yep crazy man that was that guy's
tweet
ghost crusader says around the 16 minute
mark tim says right like the boss from
office space
that's who we're channeling here that's
right
mccall says greetings from sweden just
want to say that i love all of you guys
want to shout at my newborn daughter
iris that came to the world a few days
ago congratulations nice congrats
so what's that burger place in sweden
hamburger i don't know all i know is
they have these like halloumi
cheeseburgers like it's not it's not
meat it's like fried cheese on a burger
it's so good it sounds good yeah i love
that place
sweden was fun man but
but it was like kind of creepy because
we were getting spot on and stuff
yeah
ian hall says luke has his has his head
out of his butt unlike 95 percent of
democrats that's i don't i wouldn't go
that far
[Laughter]
it's a compliment to say your head is
not in your butt that's such a kind well
there's so many people with their heads
up their butts that you know true it's a
rare thing that's luke i just want to
point that's like the nicest thing
anyone's willing to say about you
she said she loved me and potatoes but
you know luke like i guess his head's
not in his butt
all right bobcat says glad to see a
guest on who's almost as cool as an army
forward observer tommy would you support
legislation to allow everyone to conceal
carry a gau-8
what is what is it was that it's it's uh
just a really big gun
no so uh yeah i don't um
anything that impedes upon the second
amendment i'm uh
not good but everything does yeah yeah
that honestly i do i don't think that
you should even have to have a um
have to have a permit to carry i think
so repeal the nfa yeah i'm fine with
that yeah yeah 100 i just think a lot of
this stuff i mean it's very clear now
what about owning nuclear weapons i mean
look at the reality is i mean you can't
get a hold of one so
so many people saw i had somebody asked
me that at a debate one time we're
actually not a debate i was that uh
suffolk gop kid committee meetings what
about rocket launchers i'm like do you
have enough money for rock i don't have
enough money for rocket launcher so i
don't think that should be the
restriction is whether or not we're
allowed to own one i mean we can't
afford one so that's just not the
reality you can't have access to it and
if you are rich enough you can still get
one sure absolutely you can it's that
you know i mean so i just think that no
i just think permanent stupid i think
that our founding fathers the second
amendment was there for a reason the
reason was to prevent tyranny not to
hunt i don't care what joe biden says
about kevlar deer i think it's the
dumbest thing in the world he obviously
knows nothing about ballistics but
that's not what it's for it's not even
really to defend yourself it was to
protect us against tyranny and which is
astounding if you think about it
a group of guys who just got finished
throw overthrowing the government to
establish their own country they thought
it best that the second amendment that
our citizens should be able to overthrow
us
but it was more than that it was enemies
foreign and domestic right so there was
concern about foreign invasion sure yeah
as well as an internal conflict and they
said the people this is what i love when
i see all these memes that are like
well-regulated militia and i'm like what
part of the people right the right of
the people we the people it says the
right of the people to keep in bear arms
like it doesn't say the right of the
well-regulated militia
but they're willfully ignorant so what
can you say
also no you make the perfect point no
one's willing to look at just the most
basic elements of the historical context
here they had just finished fighting a
war against their government
establishing independence people like
yeah i think they wanted guns to hunt
yeah
i mean of course you had to have guns to
hunt they didn't yeah walmart you
weren't going to get steaks at walmart
they'd give their kids guns right when
they would go out to hunt they'd hand
their 12 year old son a musket yep you
can't do that these well actually you
can see yeah yeah yeah
it's funny when when i hear people say
like should kids be like have guns and
i'm like you can
like in the presence of the parent
and and i think you mean parental rights
actually exist yeah huh it's crazy isn't
it not every state though i mean look at
new jersey new york maryland all right
let's read some more
draconaforce2 says here's my second
super chat ever in recognition of my
military pcs from japan back to the
states i'll be honest with everyone i
hate that i'm going back to the states
would rather be deployed to the desert
wow
that's sad yeah man
whenever i would travel the world for
these news stories i would always be
really happy to be back in the united
states absolutely i couldn't wait to
come back every time i mean and i think
honestly comfort then yeah i think i
think the majority of people who say
america sucks and their you know talk
about wanting to the downfall of the
nation um i think they need to spend
some time abroad go to go to these
countries that you think are these like
look at venezuela you think venezuela is
so great you think that nation that form
of government is so great go visit yeah
me and tim right there let's go it's not
fun yeah go live there for a while stay
there for a month
good luck surviving
i got accused of being a spy when i went
to venezuela and was forced to flee the
country not just go to sweden and norway
and come back and tell me how great they
are yeah go to venezuela go to turkey go
to egypt and then come back and tell
norway good afternoon are not socialists
yeah they're not even that great they're
capitalists they're capitalist nations
with robust social welfare systems
yeah that there's a there's a big big
big difference venezuela nationalizes
industry right we pay for their military
i don't want to hear well actually
sweden is the largest weapons exporter
that's true too
so go to go to afghanistan go to see go
to these places where they have
extremists in charge go everywhere you
know go check out these things and see
what it is that's the difference is
people who have that experience they
look at our freedoms here very
differently yes whenever people tell me
like sweden is so nice i'm like bro they
make weapons
like they are the largest weapons
exporter per capita of course they're
doing well right selling what
whatever
and i keep your furniture ian hall says
that's right bypass the soros bought
da's vote for a sheriff that will uphold
the law they can press charges and the
d.a can get stuffed
well there you go i guess
all right let's see josh froman says
surprise you didn't all have pistols on
your hips as you walked around last
night also cops lied to you you have
every right to film them under the first
amendment they are public servants
well
we have the cameras running i mean it's
an issue of
do we want to ask the police to come and
and try and deal with a very security
sense a sensitive security issue and
then be like also we're going to film
all of the things you're doing
that's one of the frustrations i have
too right now is people treat uh our
police officers like garbage nobody
cares about it nobody cares about them
anymore nobody thinks about their frame
of mind that's why really honestly the
way that you handled it uh and the way
that your entire team handled it
yesterday was great it is tough um you
know i don't want cops coming in here
for no reason sure but consider you guys
are respectful you guys were i mean and
they were respectful i i think that that
goes a long way well you know we
we need some some way to deal with this
yeah you know so there's private
security there's there's police uh i
will say so what this was referring to
when we had the bomb squad come out they
told us not to film sure and uh yeah we
have security cameras filming the entire
everything right everything on this
property is filmed we didn't hold up an
expensive 3000 camera rig in their face
as they did it because we are not here
to just piss off the guys who are trying
to help us with a security threat
if it was like
they showed up unannounced and were
there's a conflict between us i'd be
like we are filming this sure if it's
like thank you for coming and helping us
we're gonna let you do your job yeah
look i'm not i'm i'm i'm not gonna uh
yeah i got issued my issues with cops
but
i'm not an anarchist you know michael
malus is much more the anarchist than me
i'm more towards
i'm not a big person and big on cops or
whatever but you know i recognize some
of it i think it's important to film and
document everything but you could do it
respectfully without you know being
appropriate to somebody right
and we have we have security cameras
everything in the house and all that
stuff i'm just trying to make sure we
keep tensions at a minimum but you know
i don't know maybe maybe luke will just
film maybe you just do it
what is this someone says they got
michael cobb says watching the january 6
in the background in omg they're wanting
war it's crazy i never knew the civil
war would be started by liz cheney
[Laughter]
yeah but i mean i don't even i think
that's not i don't even know if that's a
joke the chinese have a long history of
starting wars
who thought
he wouldn't want to start a woman
she's like january 6 hearing i'm going
to put together a list of all the things
we need to buy from halliburton lockheed
martin she was like sweden she was like
the insurrectionists have weapons of
mass destruction
if there is a one percent chance that's
right we don't want to have to find out
tomorrow on the new yellow mushrooms
it's actual yellow cake but whatever
every time they heard that i was just
like please
one life says i'm here for the coffee
brand coffee and to hear more about
graphene glad you are all safe real
america on your side yeah jeremy gave us
like a thousand dollars last night yeah
that's why this was fun i actually tried
to figure out how to do this i don't
know nothing about technology i tried to
figure out how to do the super chat to
put my website up there
i was like i can't figure it out i don't
know yeah i gave up so actually sheamus
plug go to tommyeltman.com there you go
ryan prices tim and crew really cool
seeing your billboard on the stevenson
going into chicago near the old
neighborhood i have since moved out of
there but people in this country and in
chicago need to be exposed in the real
world to better media and content we uh
we got some new ads up in times square
we have a luke rutkowski billboard i'm
surprised my notes fit on the billboard
but i have my mom i have like all my
like old high school friends messaging
me be like you made it bro yeah
i'm like i don't even care about this
stuff but it is pretty cool i said to
luke did your mom
i bet your mom never thought you running
around with a high-end camera yelling at
politicians would result in screaming at
them getting arrested
we put up michael malus as well because
he's we're big fans and good friends and
so we got a good quote from him he says
the corporate press gives you the
narrative tim cast gives you the news
but we had a plural some people are
questioning the singular poll because it
says the corporate press give you the
narrative tim cast gives you the news
because the corporate press was was
plural so who cares it's it's about
getting the
and if you see some of these and if you
see them in chicago i haven't seen the
one in chicago yet if you could take
some photos and send them to me on
twitter twitter
the ones in chicago are just vinyl of me
yeah but the billboard one time square
is got you on it yeah if if people have
some photos at luke we are changed no i
said it yesterday and i absolutely mean
it man i really do appreciate everything
you guys do i know it's a lot of work um
and
you guys doing this for so long you guys
did at the right time in in history
which is great um but this is where the
news is this is the future of the news
right here long form really is we had
one other ad we put up we put up a
billboard in times square for will of
the people the original song by tim cast
so there's a big
40-foot digital billboard for will of
the people the original song and music
video by tim kiss and it shows the
orange sky with the statues being pulled
down and we're uh we're planning our
album release we've already got we have
a bunch of songs uh actually this is
really cool news we've tracked a bunch
of demos we're talking with some
producers out of nashville and we're
hoping to have i i guess you can call it
an ep or an album maybe eight to ten
songs released by august so that will be
the will of the people full full album
really something like that cool we'll
buy a bunch of ads everywhere
it'll be fantastic yeah we've got a
bunch of really cool songs we're just
recording earlier shane from tales from
the inverted world was doing some vocals
because he used to be in a band very
exciting stuff happening
all right wahoo mcdaniel says no diesel
shortage tim where are you getting this
info i am an uh i own an oilfield mfg
company and have a trucking division my
fuel supplier said no chance of a
shortage any time soon here in west
texas can i come skateboard with y'all
some time love the show oh i mean
we got to figure out some kind of uh
yeah the challenge is insurance that's
why we can't really have people coming
and skating we want to try and figure
out some kind of event i will say the
diesel shortage google it um i i know
that sounds a bit maybe maybe might
sound kind of something but i mean it uh
i was reading a bunch of news and
they're all warning about detail
shortages
so i don't i don't know you mean you
mean brave search it brave search it
that's right yeah we use the brave
browser for everything we used to say
another phrase but that that one got
compromised yeah
geez yeah
go
[Laughter]
i wrote that joke hoping they would do
something wrong
and then all these years later they did
now the time time has come
all right dad teaches and words to my
son says judge judges here in kansas
will take custody from you if you
homeschool even when the judge is
breaking the law even when you try to do
right by your kids the judge will remove
them and nobody in state will do
anything maybe you shouldn't live in
kansas in germany too i hear about
horror stories of parents being arrested
because they're they try to homeschool
their children so there are
jurisdictions in states
that are absolutely totally draconian
sure
all right alexander nelson says while
abolishing the department of education
is a start
it won't fix its sending to the state uh
fix it sending to the states 40 cents of
every dollar for education in the state
of illinois goes to pensions
wait what did it say how much
40 cents of every dollar
well gives you 50 options that's why i
really love you know the
decentralization of power i think it's
why our founding fathers won it it gives
us 50 options it is the kindest way to
govern it gives the citizens 50 options
well like with the public education
system in illinois what not a lot of
people realize is that the schools of
course are funded by the local property
taxes so in areas that are wealthier the
teachers make more but when the pension
system kicks in that's just the state in
general so there can be people who are
like working
in a wealthy chicago suburb making 100
10 120 grand a year as a gym teacher
and then before retirement they'll give
them extra fluff work so their income
increases yes and then they're living
off of illinois pension system which
means people who like live and work in
impoverished parts of the inner city
making forty thousand dollars a year
have to give a portion of their income
to the government like 20 of all their
money to the government to pay for
somebody to to live for 20 years at 90k
a year on their state-funded pension
it's insane
and the idea that that's fair that's
caring that's communal we're on the left
and we support these policies because we
care about the little guy you care about
forcing the little guy to pay for the
favors you're giving to your friends and
the people who made it into the right
part of the system we have a super chat
from the quartering who says not even
the swat team could stop the quenching
power of coffee brand coffee wow code
tim cast will save you on single orders
on our six amazing coffee blends six
organic teas three have heavenly hot
cocoas if you don't buy the swatters win
wow so uh that that tim cast code does
nothing jeremy has not done any deal
with us no but i suppose he did give us
like a thousand dollars yesterday so
yeah thank you by the way see that's the
funny thing about like buying ads on the
show it's like big super chats just
appear and everyone sees it
all right
the texan 83 says tim you need to listen
to wings for marie from tools ten
thousand days album it's maynard's
realization of why his mother believes
like she did despite the bad things that
happened to her oh really i will
definitely check that out because i
gotta tell you man
we're driving in the car and then
youtube you know recommended judith and
so i played it and i haven't listened to
it like 10 years and just the guitar
the vocals the writing is just
brilliant so i'll definitely check out
this one wings for marie that's cool
that's cool i'll check it out right for
the show actually
dangness says when luke traveled to
epstein island what vaccinations did he
get none ooh
none
no we all know that you were first in
line for the cobra vaccine when you
heard fauci was given
to anyone who took it how dare you
spread such blasphemy here what were you
drinking before the show no no no no no
no no no you don't even
you're gonna get personal let's get
personal right here what kind of
flourated drink were you drinking before
i didn't raise water
i was having a little budweiser after a
hard day that's all you got
is there fluoride in budweiser yes there
is like like
most beers have a large amount of flour
you were just chugging tap water earlier
no it wasn't
[Laughter]
it's hilarious the only thing anyone
just heard was rabble rabble rabbit yeah
well
it was yeah yeah luke made some points
you guys didn't need to hear them yeah
fluoride drinker
seems like take turns luke doesn't brush
his teeth because he doesn't want the
floor oh my gosh i have natural
toothpaste charcoal all right evie uh ev
jones says matthew 10 38
he that taketh not his cross and
followeth after me is not worthy of me
he that findeth his life shall shall
lose it and uh he that loseth his life
for my sake shall find it
ah
pat 210 says christianity wasn't meant
for everyone
thanks the point only the chosen ones
will make it oh man i think that's true
all right there was a good super chat
about uh
jesus and his swords
because someone expanded upon what i was
talking about i was reading it was like
the state was coming to kill him so i
was like hey guys we need weapons yeah
this is actually at the last supper that
he said this and the context was that
judas was about to portray him and he
was at the last suburb with his
disciples and he's like just so you know
this is coming and you should be
prepared the interesting thing is uh
when they did come and
um one of his disciples cut off the ear
of one of the priest's guard right peter
yeah
jesus's first action was to heal him he
healed him yep can you imagine what that
guard was thinking yeah i'd be like hey
guys maybe we've got the wrong guy yeah
but but that's not good
but that's us right because because
christ heals us and we we go on to keep
sinning yeah all right here's ssj says
not only did jesus tell his disciples to
sell their cloak because he was about to
be put to death but when he said he who
lives by the sword will die by it was
after the romans caught him in the dead
of night and peter cut off the ear of a
soldier yeah
so what he was like was he warning the
soldier
i think so i don't know anything sheamus
i don't know i i just i try to be really
careful about like offering up any
biblical interpretation about a passage
i haven't like specifically studied
extensively and i think
yeah it'd be a good rule of thumb there
yeah because not a lot of people read
like people don't realize when you're
reading through scripture like you are
reading a translation and if you want
the most solid understanding and
interpretation of that you should go to
a higher theological source particularly
one that's like familiar with the greek
and latin like every time i've ever come
across a controversial
not not every time but many of the times
when i'll come across like a more
controversial passage in scripture
someone will make an argument to me
based on the original languages and it
just it changes my perspective in a way
that i would not have gained if i had
just sat there and read the english so
be really careful look at the root words
of hebrew aramaic greek it definitely
changes i mean just the id the word love
alone there's so many different versions
of it so
but i mean i more importantly and this
is what i always tell people certainly
as a nordic minister you can you can use
scripture to justify anything yeah and
the devil scripture that's any faith
yeah any faith can use scripture their
scripture their sacred text to justify
anything uh the reality is you gotta
understand it in context
both with uh in the time that was
written in and in the creator so
yeah i definitely think it's a good idea
to not just uh spout off at stuff and
i'm very careful of it yeah
yeah yeah we got big sloppy says tommy i
donated to your campaign want a yard
sign but don't know how to get one i
convinced my mom to watch yesterday's
show for the first time because you were
a guest was great was a great first show
tim oh thanks man uh yeah definitely go
go to tommy altman.com donate if you did
uh message me on instagram tommy altman
i didn't do anything clever message me
there and i'd love to get you one ladies
and gentlemen if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel and share the
show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have that members only show up around 11
p.m tonight these are not family
friendly but they are a lot of fun so
we'll talk about some some some
interesting things check it out you can
follow the show at tim cast irl on
instagram where we post clips every
single day you can follow me there at
tim cast or also on twitter tommy do you
want to shout out anything else no i
mean yeah check it check us out on
twitter check us out on instagram it's
tommy altman uh facebook i think it's
tommy4va it's tommy altman.com hey
listen i really appreciate you guys
having me and i appreciate uh you know
everybody that did donate and give
online that's really nice of you but
appreciate you guys having me i
appreciate all the hard work you guys
are doing seriously we have to engage we
really do have to engage i think the
getting the next generation to engage is
critical if uh we're gonna continue to
have this experiment of freedom that we
have yeah man thanks for coming um i
have a youtube channel called
youtube.com forward slash we are change
something odds been happening ever since
i got on the show this week uh youtube
ranks your video one to ten one's great
ten's bad all my videos this week have
been tens i don't know what's going on
maybe i've tripped something in the
algorithm but go check it out uh
subscribe click the notification button
and i i think you guys would love the
intro that i released today on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
and uh sheamus uh you you weren't that
unbearable today i think you know what i
appreciate that and i was i was feeling
similarly about you until that last
comment
i guess that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
uh i i see why your videos were tense
this week but
i run youtube no you dare you oh my god
i run a youtube channel called freedom
tunes you guys are gonna love it our
videos have not all been tense this week
but
today we're actually dealing with a nine
even though it's a really good video
that you guys should go check out i
think you'll really enjoy we were
watching it before the show everyone was
cracking up i think you should go check
it out you should also go to
freedomtunes.com we want to get
independent from big tech so we just
launched our own website we have a
membership section where for five bucks
a month you're gonna get an extra
cartoon every week that only members get
you're also gonna get behind the scenes
content we got a bunch of videos up
there already you'll be supporting
independent content getting extra
content i really hope you all enjoy it
freedomtunes.com i'm having such
flashbacks to having three younger
brothers right now you two are
ridiculous but it's hilarious i
appreciate it i'm curious to see if
pierogies or potatoes win tomorrow night
friday night you guys follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sour patch lids
um and yeah
i think tomorrow for dinner we should
just do pierogies and like potatoes see
who wins and we'll have like a bunch of
different kinds yeah yeah that's great
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you